nobody that's a leader
would not do what i did and i know
there's a risk there's a danger but
that's okay
i just left walter reed medical center
and i learned so much in moroni virus
don't be afraid of it you're going to
beat it we have the best
medical equipment be afraid of it feel
great like better than i have in a long
time
be afraid of it i didn't feel so good
don't be afraid of it you're going to
beat it we have to put
on a virus don't be afraid of it and now
i'm better
maybe i'm immune i don't know be afraid
of it don't
let it dominate don't let it take over
your life be afraid of it
don't let that happen you're the
greatest country in the world afraid of
it
as your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger do it but i had to do it
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentary
[Music]
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
convalescent strong antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection convalescence
which is the only possibility
because of operation
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescent
virus
[Music]
convalescence
convalescent
it's my favorite show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
okay all right we don't have it it's too
busy a night for i mean we're not doing
a concert here we're doing politics my
friends so i am
i am here uh half past
the hour as promised and we have
competing town halls this evening
from miami on nbc much to the chagrin of
many
donald trump will be holding a short
town hall
don't know if it's stamina related but
it will be a short town hall
and then over on abc news
joseph r biden jr will be holding a
town hall from philadelphia moderated by
george stephanopoulos it will be longer
uh originally scheduled for two hours
now it may only be 90 minutes so as i
mentioned yesterday the plan is going to
be we will start with the trump town
hall
since trump doesn't have i guess the
energy for more
we'll do the trump town hall first then
we'll switch
as people know over to the joe biden
town hall we're going to get a little
bit of both it's going to be very
different
dramatically different town halls uh for
sure
now the plan is going to be at the top
of the hour
we will be going exclusive to youtube
why this is not an
insult to people watching on twitch this
is not an
anti-semitic or otherwise racialized
attack on people
watching on facebook it's just that
after talking to all of our various
platform partners and advisors we've
determined that
the safest place for the actual
event stream is youtube tonight that's
not always the case
there are different very mundane
technical boring reasons for these
different things
we're not going to waste time on that
but as we close in on the top of the
hour
we will we're essentially going to pinch
off two streams
both twitch and facebook and we will be
uh
live on youtube at the top of the hour
for for the duration so i'm glad that
you are all here
it is an incredible day where we started
with
in theory debate number two tonight um
and then because trump caught the virus
and was wildly contagious
um the debate was moved to remote trump
said he didn't want to do remote because
people could cut him off
so then it was going to be just a biden
town hall and then trump went and found
himself another town
hall so that's where we are today and we
don't you know we would love to have a
debate tonight we don't have it
um and so we will deal with what we have
of course in high definition we will get
all of our various streams switched over
to hd the highest
resolution that we can find for for our
beautiful viewers
um i am going to get some uh super chats
read by folks i saw that 12
gift subs were already gifted over on
twitch which i really really appreciate
um and we had a very strong cheer
from ireman 1136 bits i don't know if
there's some kind of poetic meaning
to 1136 but interesting
nonetheless and um oh i
i will there is a warning upcoming about
uh
yeah there's a warning upcoming about
membership uh prices yeah that
i will get to that just a few super
chats here
um marlene marianne
zimmerman says david if trump wins
you're welcome to come live in our
basement
we live in the center of copenhagen
imagine if i go from living in my mom's
basement to living in marianne's
basement
the patriots would love that ant and
sharon say hello sir hoping for oh the
sir routine
hoping for the best from biden trump
will be slinging lies and insults like
any good sixth grader big love david
zesty african says from the standpoint
of obese men running into the crowd and
kissing men and beautiful women
what policy are you most willing to hold
biden to well
listen um biden must get something done
on climate something real
now if he doesn't have the senate can he
really get anything done it's not clear
um
but i want i want real uh
accomplishments
on climate and i want them now
chaka seki says david can you give a
shout out to joe and magda in beantown
they have treated me to a wonderful
evening
yes shout out to joe and magda beautiful
hey me says link to the music good stuff
just google soundcloud
joseph woodward it's the first result
that comes up
um alexander salinas says do you believe
in person votes will be tampered
i think overwhelmingly votes are going
to be counted now
if you only have a 10 000 vote margin in
a state like michigan for example
then you could be in trouble but i have
an interview that i recorded today with
congresswoman debbie
mccarsell powell we did an interview in
spanish
for my spanish show and an interview in
english
for the english show does that sound
right yeah spanish interview for the
span yeah that's right
and we actually talk about that and
we'll be publishing that
soon so fed up says i have covered
i'm sorry to hear that i already voted
for biden i just hope i'm here to see
trump ousted please vote yes
please please vote
um verbal diarrhea wants me to kiss them
that's just a weird super chat that's
going to push me back over to twitch
thanks to snuggles
for the sub ayub has subscribed
troixa has gifted a membership
patty patty patty patty patty has
subscribed with prime
and the great david chadman continues to
gift subs
uh it's like a fire hose of gifted subs
it's really something else
uh thanks also to paula barrows who says
greetings from amherst where our numbers
of coveted cases have risen by 25
paula i don't know if you mean amherst
massachusetts or amherst new york
but i know that amherst massachusetts is
uh not going in the right direction
as as we might say speaking of cases by
the way let's just do a brief review
today let me just refresh 64
000 cases so today was the worst day
in terms of new cases in months and i
can tell you
so if we had 64 when did we last see
64. i guess you have to go all the way
back
so we had 63 when did we last have 64.
you have to so today was the worst day
since july 31st
and if you look at the seven day moving
average you see that it bottomed
on september 12th and then the average
has been
increasing um if you look at deaths
which tend to lag
by about uh two to three weeks you see
that those have been
flat now since about 10 days after
the the new the bottom of cases and the
unfortunate expectation is that we will
start to see
the death count take death count tick up
so we do still have a pandemic going on
here
um that that is still that is still
happening
stewart says get your ass over to
scotland david
i would love to once travel is a thing
junior extreme says
trump will get more viewers because we
crave entertainment over
common sense in the us it's partly why
we are in this political mess in the
first place
sadly i think you're right jop
van warden says hey david watching from
the netherlands let me just say that
this two-party system in the usa
is bunkers keep fighting the good fight
i would go further
i would say it's bonkers and bunkers
it's both it makes me want to go into a
bunker
and it's bonkers it's both if you're
just joining us welcome
i have been advised really strongly
that most left-wing youtube channels
have abandoned
live stream plans for tonight once the
debate got cancelled
so i was told by uh by by our great
youtube rep
who's the best rep i've ever had he's
done things i've nev
he's done things lots of people haven't
even heard of for us
you understand um he said we could
actually have a have a
a pretty solid stream tonight because a
lot of people have
bailed who were planning to stream the
debate so we're here
uh and i'm i'm welcoming everybody
uh okay oh
this is very very important did you guys
see
the text messages that rudy giuliani
received i'm going to show you guys a
text message
this was posted to my subreddit this is
supposedly a text message that hunter
biden
sent to his daughter naomi biden look at
this
the photo below is a screenshot of a
text message from hunter biden to his
daughter naomi on january 3rd 2019.
this describes the amount kicked back to
the boss joe biden check this out
naomi wrote to hunter i'm sorry hunter
wrote to naomi
the deals on membership are too good
at davidpakman.com membership they might
not be legal in some states
can you imagine the trouble that hunter
biden is now going to be in as a result
of these
uh text messages with which rudy
giuliani
um uncovered that is really really
shocking this is deep state stuff i mean
it's
it's unbelievable but in all seriousness
guys
the entire hunter biden story may be
completely fake
um i do have a i do have a clip i
published to my youtube channel
um that's weird someone just requested
five dollars for gas to go vote
on venmo somebody i don't even know
that's weird
um no we published a story about a half
hour ago to our youtube channel about
the hunter biden story
but one of the real red flags was
instead of having actual screenshots of
emails i don't know how many of you guys
noticed this
it was as if i had just like opened up
notepad
and said hey check out this email obama
wrote me
from barack obama
to david pakman
subject
the meth right
dear david thank you so much for the
great meth you gave me
sincerely barack
h obama if i could screenshot this
and say wow look at this email this is a
crazy crazy email
so far that's what's been released and
of course there are all sorts of other
reports coming out that it may be
planned propaganda i mean it's we're
going to keep talking about it but if
you want to
get uh caught up to speed on the hunter
biden story check out the clip that i
released
um just about 40 45 minutes ago or so
and we will some people don't like my
typing accuracy
here's the problem when i'm streaming i
keep my mouse where i would
normally have the keyboard so my
keyboard is off center
so i'm typing like this and that's very
difficult to do
and this keyboard is is just terrible
it's wireless but look at how flat it is
i have no
i have no length and barely any girth on
it so it's just it's tough i'm doing the
best i can but my ti
i do type about 120 per minute 120 per
minute is roughly uh
where i'm at 120 to 140. and i will
stick to that
doctors have seen my typing tests and
they said wow
uh wow other super chats coming in
oh hold on a couple new members to thank
sorry i'm in the wrong folder
i do want to say thanks to elite wagon
brenner
who is new member number one today and
matt
miles who is new member number two fair
warning
i am told that the doj is now
investigating our obscene membership
discounts so just fair warning
for uh for everybody ramsay
el hidari says oh i skipped one ramsay
al hidari says david hello from tokyo
keep up the good work thank you
bronx bjorn says people need to be
reminded of the sickening things that
have happened
past tense trump shenanigans being daily
cause
folk to lose focus on why he needs to go
well said fidel cashflow
says his name is hassan i don't know
what that means but okay
sean says what are your thoughts on the
fake ballot boxes the gop put in
california uh locations
uh deplorable i mean what what is there
to think it's absolutely outrageous
it's insane yabbot says great interview
with robert jones today yeah we did an
interview with robert p
jones today about the uh white
supremacist
origins the white supremacist overlap
with certain christian denominations
very very interesting very very
interesting oliver minshall says do you
think
balier or ballier has a chance in kansas
i don't know i don't know enough about
that race to comment
um oliver wilde says whoever's making
these great songs please include the
jesse lee amazing sound bite
yeah so joe if joe woodward is watching
who's been creating all of these great
um
uh remixes and original original songs
that's an interesting idea doing some
kind of song including
elements from my interview with jessie
lee peterson i think that that would be
very interesting
thanks to hannah reloaded for the raid
with a party of 77
i'm not familiar with the hannah
reloaded
twitch channel let's see what it is
hannah reloaded
um it looks like it
is chad's and karen's i don't know what
chuds and karen's are
trans leftist streamer talking politics
debunking conspiracy theories and having
a good time doing it
i enjoy both dungeons and the dragons
turn offs include elon musk okay very
interesting well thank you hannah
reloaded for the raid very much
appreciate it
um also thanks to d taina for the
twitch sub and supreme bun as well as
lord bibermort or bibermore potentially
that's a soft t on the end
and elephants elephants very very much
appreciate that
hoopla cake mace says hi david only
started listening recently but you have
gotten me interested in politics in
america
as well as at home here in nova scotia
canada
thanks for making this nonsense make
some sense crack a beer for me buddy
yeah i have some beautiful uh some
beautiful belgians in my fridge
maybe maybe we will crack one at some
point
lost a bunch of super chats here let me
go back to where we were
average action says thoughts on
progressive international don't know a
thing about it
benjamin griber says voted for the first
time ever in north carolina
love it love it love it love it kero's
pictures says is it mere does pence have
a ronald reagan vibe
no super measured and rehearsed tone
yeah he has a
he's measured and rehearsed but i don't
think there's a reagan vibe
paula clarifies that she was referring
to my old stomping grounds in amherst
massachusetts
megan says can you wish my twin sister
molly a happy birthday thanks for all
you do she put me onto your content well
if she's your twin sister it must be
your birthday as well right unless
there's something i don't understand
about human reproduction
happy birthday to molly curran and
to megan curran if indeed it is uh
both of your birthdays king is it king
chasma or king cosma i live
in new jersey do i still have an
obligation to vote for biden
yes we need to run up the score in every
state
nothing is safe vote as if your vote
determines
trump versus biden this is a unique
election and i encourage
everybody to do that thanks to tim brown
who is new member number three at
jointpakman.com and richard whitaker
is new member number four today very
much appreciate that
uh what else did i have oh there was one
other post from my subreddit i did want
to call to your attention
i i actually agree with this check out
what this person says
let me get a little more powerful zoom
for you guys there it is
opinion pacmanite is a is an idolizing
term and should not be used to describe
oneself
i'm a very longtime fan of the david
pakman show but i wouldn't say i'm a
pacmanite or a cedarin
or a bidean baidean or a trumpus let's
not idolize
flawed humans yes i'm sure david has
flaws
even though i don't know of any i like
that even if it's tongue-in-cheek terms
can get a life of their own also it's
just not a good look for david to have
people referring to themselves as
pacmanites
part of david's appeal is that i can
somewhat trust that his audience are not
political zealots i'm not saying this is
a huge issue now
i've just seen it a few times already
and want to voice a concern
i completely agree with this i am
against the deification of
any elected official these are just
people flawed people
who may uh may be right about certain
things
and uh there i should there should be no
nicknaming of audience members no pack
heads no pacmaniacs no pacmanites
uh none of it absolutely none of it and
if i just gave you some ideas for even
more new terms about it
then i guess i made a mistake um
lala says just fought with my far right
dad about the koni
coney barrett situation concerned for
the future so i'm contributing to my
favorite
independent media platform thank you
pablo says just became a citizen this
past september and filled out my ballot
today
hopefully all goes as planned yes indeed
yes indeed vincent van
brow says hey david i just joined from
europe glad to have you here
if you're just joining us ladies and
gentlemen we are uh
just about 10 minutes from the start of
donald trump's town hall
in miami florida joe biden also holding
a town hall this evening
in philadelphia because the tru the
biden town hall
is longer what we agreed together
yesterday is we will start with the
trump town hall
then go to the biden town hall and get a
little bit of both
i am going to remind everybody close to
the top of the hour because of reasons
of copyright that i don't want to get
into but this is we've made a decision
we're going to pinch off the streams on
facebook and twitch and we will be
for the bulk of the event only live on
youtube so you can come join us there
youtube.com thedavidpakmanshow if you're
watching on facebook or twitch
okay it's not an insult sometimes we've
pinched off the youtube stream and gone
exclusive on twitch
different combinations for different
events and that's what we're going to be
doing
um tonight and if you don't like it then
i'm sorry
i genuinely am i'm sorry
okay mar says hopefully there is
substance spoken today unlike what came
out of the mouths of both
senator black senators blackburn and
kennedy at the hearing for barrett yeah
they were both vile
vile and disgusting steven robbins says
d-man
it's ray gun since you refused to come
on my show you should have me on your
spanish show to talk immigration
let's look at that strongly stephen
let's do it
jamie lee clay says hi from sheffield
england we are watching with
horror for from the uk trump is
ruining america very well said
dc blunt says producer pat looks like
joe burrow someone has to say it shout
out to producer lewis
real ogs know what's good i don't know
who joe burrow is so i'm unable to
comment on that
uh okay
yeah i already did the illegal
membership thing yeah well so let me
just mention before we get started
please sign up please sign up we we do
have a incredibly modest target of 25
new members today
that means join pakman.com that's the
one place you can also do patreon if you
want
our number one funding source is when
people sign up on joinpakman.com okay so
if you like what we do if you like the
streaming we've been doing covering
biden and trump events debates primary
results all of this different stuff
and the youtube clips and the audio
podcast and all of this different stuff
grab a membership at joinpakman.com now
you will see that there are people
literally right now literally right now
in the chat
saying do not fund this clown there are
people right now who are trying to take
us down
if you like what they are saying then
join the party and don't send us a penny
but if you actually think what we're
doing has some relevance some importance
and you're not down to your last dollar
i don't want anybody's last dollar last
five dollars
grab a membership at joinpakman.com the
coupon code above my head
20 20 now without the quotes okay
20 20 now without the quote the quotes
are there to delineate you understand
uh you'll save 66 and as the memberships
pop up on my screen i will thank you and
the bar here
will fill up hopefully all the way to 25
and beyond and um i i would be wrong
i would be un uh i would not be able to
live with myself if i didn't tell you
the 66 discount is
maybe against the law and certainly
immoral
so just think about that i don't want
you know william barr coming to your
door and saying we know about the
discount we know you did it
um although there are states where it is
legal and and a lot of those states are
ones where you can marry
uh your first cousin interestingly
enough there is overlap in the law there
so that that's very very interesting
uh parker peter says does anyone
remember the tara reads story it kind of
came and went i feel like that's what
will happen with biden's email
yeah i don't think the hunter biden
email a story as
it is out so far is going to make any
impact
but of course if there is more and there
have been rumors that there will be more
um maybe maybe it will make an impact
yeah and
interesting people asking if the
membership discount is unconstitutional
it's not unconstitutional oh hold on a
second you know what guys
we act i actually do have to drop the
banhammer someone now
one of these people that was saying
don't fund this show they're now
starting with some mildly xenophobic
stuff about me being a south american so
we just dropped the ban hammer bye bye
the ban hammer is free
david chadman in the chat knows it and
they are gone
gone uh we're just not gonna tolerate it
okay guys
we're just not gonna do it uh beautiful
joe sheehan says david can i get a shout
out for my wife priya we will be voting
next tuesday to flip tennessee love your
show yes
joe and priya do it do it do it do it
vote vote vote
once each obviously i'm not by saying
vote vote vote i didn't mean
vote more than once just vote a
chakaseki says can we please get
give kovida a pacifier so he doesn't
spew his viral load onto his adoring
fans
and soil his diaper he needs his bottle
of regeneron
too the funniest thing about regeneron
is that he says regeneron like that's
the medication whereas regeneron is the
company it's like me saying
they gave me pfizer it was unbelievable
pfizer cured me
uh no david chadman did not get banned
that i know of did we if
whoa hold on was david chadman
accidentally banned
that shouldn't be the case david chadman
is one of the biggest gifters of subs no
we we muted we we've banned the right
person i think
moderators please make sure david
chadman is not banned let's unban
if that was accidentally something that
took place okay
uh we are now going to move to the
portion of the evening where we will be
exclusively on youtube for copyright
purposes if you've been watching on
twitch
or facebook i apologize that i must do
this
please come over to youtube.com the
david pakman show i'll see the two
thousand of you folks over there as we
will be going into the youtube exclusive
part of the evening if you are watching
on youtube
don't do a thing don't do a thing here
we go stand by
all right and we are now uh exclusively
live on youtube let's see how many of
those people come over
we are at uh 13 000 live viewers on
youtube let's see if we get a spike
as a result of that and i guess what we
will do is
um yeah okay we're fine
we're fine okay we are two minutes from
the start of donald trump's town hall in
miami we will start with donald trump we
will then go over to the joe biden town
hall okay since the biden town hall is
longer than trump's
we are starting with the trump town hall
and we're going to cover
both of them hoopla cake may says david
that meth email bit you did had me on
the floor you are a very witty
individual thank you i it was spur of
the moment
um stephen says i live in boston too
come here dave okay oh my god we're not
this is a this is a kids show
harry says mighty pie drinks too much
bee juice my god troy masko says has the
biden campaign
denied the emails uh i i believe that
they
um what have they said i believe that
what they've said is it's conceivable
that joe biden at some point shook hands
with that russian guy
that's what i remember uh them them
saying uh you know at an event with like
100 people but i'm sure that there will
be more about this over the next
couple of days less stat says hi david
what's your opinion on the
feds pulling 4 million from the 911
treatment fund administration lining
their pockets in case
or offsetting the stimulus bill thoughts
i don't know the answer to that and i
will look into that
um n gill says i've been watching the
2016 republican primary debates
trump won because he pitched himself as
totally independent of the gop
but he's governed as a gop tool that's
why he'll lose independence this year
interesting that is not unlike many
takes that
uh that that some have been making
hollis jamison
says election called before 4 a.m
november 4th what's your bet
my bet is before midnight november 5th
meaning the end of november 4th i think
we will know
the winner by the end of november 4th
let me say thank you to a few um
oh hold on what's going on here
uh we've got a bunch of people
we've got a lot of craziness going on
here hold on all right we are expecting
this town hall
any moment i do want to say thanks to a
few new members though who signed up
mauro danielle is new member number five
today
martin cairns is new member number six
chris sisk is new member number seven
grayson dundon
is new member number eight brian steele
is new member number nine
and elenia herring is new member number
ten
very much appreciate that i see that
there are more let's take a listen to
what's going on here
miami moderated by today show anchor
savannah guthrie
is next on nbc news now powerful
okay so we're very very close there was
a fifty dollar super chat that came in
oliver wilde says very important just
because biden's speeches aren't as
entertaining
as trump's doesn't mean that what he's
saying isn't important please pay
attention please please please
vote very well said oliver
we will start with trump then go to
joseph r biden jr
and that is a very very important
message for sure
um as we as we await donald trump here
if you're just joining us welcome we are
live
exclusively on youtube this evening
remember if you aren't subscribed
please do me the favor of subscribing
this is my please clap moment
uh what's going on with these twitch
subscriber numbers since we're not on
twitch i'm just gonna close that out for
a second
and we will also close out uh
there we go just to make that a little
bit cleaner but we are actually
getting very very close to 1.1 million
subscribers on youtube which is just a
crazy
number for us so i do appreciate
everybody hitting that subscribe button
uh it is time first for the donald trump
town hall then we will go to joe biden
let's take a listen
outdoors here very clearly donald trump
but we want to say right off the top
this is not how things were supposed to
go tonight
this was supposed to be a town hall
debate between donald trump and joe
biden right but after the president
contracted covid
the debate commission announced it would
have to be a virtual debate because of
health concerns
the president then said he would not
participate in a virtual debate at that
point
joe biden scheduled a town hall tonight
in pennsylvania on another network and
now the president is doing the same
his own town hall with the same venue
format and time as nbc's town hall with
joe biden last week so the two
candidates go head to head tonight
though not face to face
each in a key battleground state and
tonight the president will be taking
questions from voters here in miami
we should mention our socially distance
and they're wearing masks and i
should say this audience looks a bit
like america it's divided
some here voted for the president in
2016 and plan to again
some support joe biden and some say they
are truly undecided we're going to get a
mix of questions on a range of topics
and we're going to get to those
questions in a moment
but first with all that to do welcome mr
president and thank you for being here
very well stated i have to say good job
thank you
we're glad you're here we're glad you're
well we send our best to the first lady
into baron
thank you do you have any remaining
symptoms from kovitz nothing whatsoever
i'm
great i feel good i was in north
carolina today
anybody who heard his speech yesterday
with a frog in his throat knows he's got
a symptom
just feel really good florida
pennsylvania we're all over the place
it's
been great you received some treatments
that are generally reserved for those
with
the most severe form of the disease how
severe were your symptoms
in particular did you have pneumonia
well i'll tell you what happened
i didn't feel good i didn't feel strong
i had a little bit of a temperature the
doctors at the white house are fantastic
as you can imagine and
they really didn't want to take a chance
and they said let's go to the hospital i
said that's okay i'm going to
you know respond to what you say and we
went having a moment to read where you
have tremendous professionals
uh they gave me regeneron and desavier
both
and i just all i know is i felt good the
following day i felt really good
did the doctors ever tell you that they
saw pneumonia on your lungs
no but they said the lungs are you know
a little bit different a little bit uh
perhaps infected and uh
i don't know i mean i didn't do too much
asking i i really felt good
i didn't have much of a problem with the
lungs i did have a little bit of a
temperature
they're infected is it i mean is it a
leech or is it coronavirus then i tested
you know i tested possibly
let's talk about testing because there's
a little bit of i guess confusion about
this and i think we can clear it up
your first positive test was thursday
october 1st
okay when was your last negative test
when did you last remember having a
negative test
well i test quite a bit and i can tell
you that before the debate
which i thought it was a very good
debate and i felt fantastically i was
i had no problem before did you test the
day of the debate
i don't know i don't even remember any
time but i continue this
after the debate like i guess a day or
so
i think it was thursday evening maybe
even late thursday evening
i tested positive that's when i first
found out
back to the debate because the debate
commission's rules it was the honor
system would be that you would come with
the negative test you say you don't know
if you got a test on the day of the
debate no problem again the doctors do
it i don't ask them like that
all the time and did you take a test
though on the day of the day
you know if you ask the doctor they'll
give you a perfect answer
and i was in great shape for the debate
and it was only after the debate
like a period of time after the debate
that
i said that's interesting and they took
a test and a testimony
do you take a test every single day no
no but i take a lot of tests
okay and you don't know if you took a
test the day of the debate
uh possibly i did possibly i didn't but
you know the doctor is very accurate
information
and it's not only that doctor it's many
doctors or one thing can not be tested
at the debate he had to say don't worry
we've gotten a test
but i was in great shape for the debate
and sometime after the debate i tested
positively let's talk about
that's when they decided to let's go
okay good i
hopefully provided some clarity let's
talk about the event that was held at
the white house
on the saturday before you tested
positive subsequent to that
13 people connected to that event tested
positive there was an outdoor reception
you've seen the pictures there was an
indoor reception people were not wearing
masks my question to you is at this
point in the pandemic
knowing what we know shouldn't you have
known better shouldn't the white house
know better than to hold an event like
that
well they do a lot of testing in the
white house they test everybody
including me but they test everybody
and something happened but as far as the
mask is concerned i'm good with masks
i'm okay with mass i tell people wear
mess but just the other day they came
out with a statement that 85 percent of
the people that wear masks
catch it
85 of the 100 million people wearing
masks have caught it the numbers don't
make any sense
i also knew that hey i'm president
i have to see people i can't be in a
basement i can't be
in a room i can't be i have to be out
you can see people with a mask though
right
i can but people with masks are catching
it all the time i mean if you look at
the governor of virginia
he was known for a mask if you look at
tom tiller
he always had a mask and they caught it
well there are pictures of tom tillis
actually with one of um judge barrett's
kids not wearing a mask but you know
chris christie
he was part of your debate prep he was i
believe at that event
he came out tonight he was sick very
sick he was in the hospital for about a
week
he came out tonight and said i was wrong
not to wear a mask
well i mean he has to say that i think
it's great he's a friend of mine he's a
good guy
and wrong or not wrong you have to
understand
as president i can't be locked in a room
someplace for the next year and just
stay and do nothing
and every time i go into a crowd i was
with
the parents of our fallen heroes these
people are the most incredible people
and they came up to me and they would
hug me and they would
touch me and i'm not going to not let
them do it
there was an event with the gold star
family that's the day after the supreme
court
event with the most incredible people
you've ever seen
and i could have chosen not to talk to
him or to keep everybody away
and you know what as and i don't think
that's probably where
it was caught but maybe it was i was
going to say you bring it up
yourself i mean are you trying to
suggest that do you believe a grieving
military family gave you covet
no i don't know where it came from you
don't know where it came from and the
doctors don't know where it came from
but as the president i have to be out
there i also know there's no one that
says you can't be out there but it's
just about wearing masks and having for
example
and i'm not blaming her i'm not saying
oh she did a terrible thing
as president i have to be out there i
can't be in a basement i can't be locked
in a very beautiful room someplace in
the white house
right and i want to see the goals to our
families and i want to see everybody
and i also say to people all the time
it's risky doing it it is risky doing
that
you're right you don't want to you want
to be a leader but you also are a leader
in a setter
of an example and if you're not wearing
a mask when your administration is
saying
best practice right now is wear a mask
no it's not foolproof
many people are getting this disease
that was sent to us by china and it
shouldn't have been allowed to happen
but many people are getting this and i
mean nobody's being blamed everybody is
working hard to get this thing
out of our country out of the world look
at what's going on in europe
massive spikes they've done a very good
job but now you take a look today at the
uk you take a look at spain and france
and italy
there's tremendous spikes but our death
rate is worse
than well not spain but those are
countries i have things right here that
will tell you exactly the opposite
the uk is up 2 500 because i knew you'd
be doing this i know you very well
the uk is up 2 500
the eu's up 722 and the united states is
down
21 but we
and what we've done has been amazing and
we have done an amazing job
and it's rounding the corner and we have
the vaccines coming and we have the
therapies coming
and i'll tell you what one thing when i
got it
i had a choice do nothing or use some of
the things that we're looking at like
in this case regeneron yeah you can
finally make something that's supposed
to be
incredible and i think that maybe i
wouldn't be doing
this discussion with you right now we
have
therapies now and cures maybe you can
use the word cure
but we have therapies that are
absolutely incredible
i want to pick up on something you just
said you said we're rounding the corner
i believe we're rounding the course
of the country approximately has had
covet that means
80 90 90 let's do the math is still
vulnerable
right there's been some talk including
from the white house lately that perhaps
it approves of what's called herd
immunity that's where
you basically just let young people and
everybody get sick
you try to protect the old people and
those who are sick and hopefully
where does she get the 10 of head at 10
would be 33 million we only know of 8
million cases
do you support herd immunity as a
strategy
essentially just let people get sick
the cure cannot be worse than the
problem itself
we did the right thing we were expected
to lose 2 million
200 000 people and maybe more than that
we're at 210
000 people one person is too much it
should have never happened because of
china
it happened because of china and you
have to get that and
understand that but it shouldn't have
happened but we were expected to lose if
you look at the original charts from
original doctors who are respected by
everybody
2 million
if you did absolutely nothing it would
be two million
the question is should the deaths be
better than
200 000 when
i left north carolina which i love i
left
pennsylvania we won a big case in
michigan because that governor has
a lockdown where nobody but her husband
can do anything he can go voting and do
whatever he wants but nobody else can
the fact is we're winning all these
cases because it's unconstitutional what
they're doing and i think they're doing
it for political reasons
but the fact is the cure you can't you
can't let this continue to go on with
the lockdowns
and i believe that on november 4th
nobody's locked down just people are
saying i'm not going to go to a lot of
these businesses
almost 40 000 people they have a
lockdown like you've never seen
now they're open it's like it goes to
them and so
it's very important people are leaving
new york
by the thousands and you didn't have a
hard time ever building it up again
so that cure that so-called cure that
you talk about it can't be worse
than the problem the problem is a bad
problem we've got more questions
so let's drop it for now we were
supposed to mention be watching you on a
debate stage right now
we're not doing that so let's clear up a
few things from the last one you were
asked point blank
to denounce white supremacy in the
moment
you didn't you asked some follow-up
questions who specifically
a couple of days later on a different
show you denounced white supremacy
for years but you always do it you
always start off with a
question you didn't ask joe biden
whether or not he denounces antifa
i watched him with lester holt
and he was asking questions like biden
was a child
well so this is a little bit of a dog
are you listening
i denounce white supremacy what's your
next question do you feel
it feels sometimes you're hesitant to do
so like you waited here we go again
every time in fact my people came i'm
sure they'll ask you the white supremacy
question
i denounce white supremacy and frankly
you want to know something i denounce
antifa
and i denounce these people on the left
that are burning down our cities that
are run by democrats
it is this theory that
uh satanic pedophile ring and that you
are the savior of that now can you just
once and for all state that that is
completely not true
[Music]
you told me but what you tell me doesn't
necessarily make it fact
i hate to say that i know nothing about
it i do know they are
very much against pedophilia
i'll tell you what i do know about i
know about antifa and i know about the
radical left and i know how violent
and real leaders call conspiracy
theories conspiracy theories
you do know i don't know no i don't know
i don't know
you start off with white supremacy i
denounce it
you start off with something else let's
go keep asking me these questions
let me just let me just tell you what i
do here about it is they are very
strongly against pedophilia
and i agree with that i mean i do agree
with that and i agree with them
they also breathe in i have no idea i
know you don't know that
okay no i don't know you just did this
do you know that okay
just this week what are you asking me
about antifa
what a country
joe biden questions about why doesn't he
condemn antifa
why does he say it doesn't exist because
you're here
antifa exists they're vicious
they're violent they kill people and
they're burning down ourselves i don't
know that antifa has killed anybody is
that true
just this week you retweeted to your 87
million followers a conspiracy theory
that joe biden orchestrated to have seal
team six the navy seal two six killed to
cover up
the the fake death of bin laden now why
would you send a lion
to your followers that was a retweet
that was
an opinion of somebody and that was a
retweet
and i do a lot of retweets and frankly
because the
media is so fake and so corrupt if i
didn't have
social media i don't call it twitter i
call it social media oh my god i
wouldn't be able to get the word out
and the word is and you know what the
word is the word is very simple
we're building our country stronger and
better than it's ever been before
and that's what's happening and
everybody knows it okay we know that's
the word
winning in a lot of states winning in a
lot of states let me ask
okay i'm glad you brought up the
election because i do want to ask about
that that's another kind of leftover
item a lot of people have asked you will
you accept a peaceful transfer of power
you have said repeatedly the only way we
lose this election is if it is rigged
now that is simply not true the fact is
either candidate
can lose fair and square without ballot
but when i see thousands of ballots
right
unsolicited ballots being given out by
the millions
and thousands of them are dumped in
dumpsters and when you see
ballots with the name trump military
ballots from our great military
and they are dumped in garbage cans we
could go all night which we won't know
one by one a single case a single day
you're talking about 150 million votes
your own fbi
director says there is no evidence of
widespread
well then he's not doing a very good job
all you have to do is pick up the papers
every day
50 000 in ohio the great state of ohio
50 000
uh in another location i think north
carolina 500 000
applications in virginia no no there's a
tremendous
problem but let me just tell you they
talk about the peaceful transfer right
they spied on my campaign and they got
caught and they spied heavily on my
campaign
and they tried to take down a duly
elected city
president and then they talked about
will you accept a peaceful transfer
and the answer is yes i will but i want
it to be an honest election
and so does everybody else when i see
thousands of ballots
dumped in a garbage can and they happen
to have my name on it
i'm not happy a q a on mail carrier
hoarded
and threw out eight bags of mail and you
were so
in doubt about our democracy our
democracy how can you say that you do
read
newspapers you do watch the news but you
watch it i do
because every day they're talking about
ballots
that are corrupt by the way if this is a
town hall is anybody else going to ask a
question
but you can win a race take a look at me
you can win a race by one percent
but why are you laying the groundwork
for that right now it's like if i don't
want to
say
[Music]
when i spent three and a half years
fighting off these maniacs
and now it turns out everything's there
that they were the ones that dealt with
how does it end up with a sycophant
nodding at every crazy thing trump says
right on screen the entire time is that
planned i don't want to transfer because
i want to win
and i think that your words will
probably reassure some folks let's get
to our first vote we've got jacqueline
lugo
now she is i told you this this audience
is truly split between y'all
you're leaning biden she voted for
clinton in 2016 she's registered as an
independent
jacqueline what's your question for the
president and hold the mic up close and
take up your mind because it's hard to
hear out here
good evening how are you uh welcome to
miami thank you very much
mr president if you knew covet 19
as you told bob woodward in february
as you told bob woodward in february was
airborne and deadlier than the flu
why did you only put in place
a travel ban from china and not put in
place
other measures mitigating the spread of
covet 19
wow potentially saving tens of thousands
of american lives well i did put it in
very early as you know
joe biden was two months behind me and
he called me xenophobic and racist and
everything else because i put it in
and it turned out that i was 100 right i
also put it on europe
very early because you saw there was a
lot of infection in europe
and it's sort of an amazing question and
i appreciate the question and respect
the question
but the news doesn't get out the right
answer because i put on a travel ban
far earlier than dr fauci thought it was
necessary who i like
far earlier than the scientist i was
actually the only one that wanted to put
it on and i did it
actually against the advice of a lot of
people including nancy pelosi who had no
clue what she was doing
and biden when i put on the travel ban
and i put it on in january the end of
january
when i put on the travel ban joe biden
and others said this is ridiculous you
don't do that
well dr fauci said i saved thousands
and thousands of lives i was early i was
extremely early when i put on the travel
ban can i ask you did your
national security advisor on january
28th in the oval office warn you that
this would be the greatest national
security risk of your administration
i read it someplace maybe woodward said
it or something but no he did not say
that
but i knew it was a big threat at the
same time
because publicly he said it wasn't i
don't want to go out and say everybody's
going to
die everybody
the guy who doesn't want to panic
anybody for nine months
was constantly saying a dangerous
immigrant caravan is coming to the us
and they're going to kill your daughters
after raping them voted for you in 2016.
she's laying into
vote for you again now her daughter was
too young to vote last time she's going
to vote for her first time in a
presidential campaign
and she is leaving biden so imagine the
dinner table at their house okay
so barbara why don't you go first and
ask your question bienvenido miami
thank you mr trump as a frontline er
doctor working through the coronavirus
pandemic
oh my god i know firsthand and i've seen
that many hospitals throughout the
united states
are suffering uh financial hardships
these
uh economic effects are trickling down
to the frontline workers we are being uh
across the country frontline workers are
being fired they're being furloughed our
salaries are being cut
and this is also happening in other
economic sectors as well including the
travel industry and hospitality
guaranteed he has no substantive
answer to whatever question is coming
going to get the united states back on
track
both in terms of the economy and the
pandemic
so it's happening we just set a record
11.4 million
jobs we are going to have a phenomenal
third quarter which will be announced
on november 1st just prior to the big
november third day where i think you'll
see a red wave
but we're going to have a tremendous
announcement i believe i mean we're
going to find out but gdp is going
through the roof
jobs real estate houses
so many things are happening so people
were saying we're going to have a 42
unemployment look this was a thing that
came into our country
and it happened a hundred more than a
hundred years ago
and it happened now they were talking
about a 42
unemployment rate
at 7.8 unemployment and people can't
even believe it
our economy is going to be next year if
we don't have somebody that raises taxes
and quadruples
taxes which they want to do and kills
everything our economy is going to be
phenomenal
next year we're going to have a
phenomenal and i'll tell you savannah we
had
the greatest economy in the history of
our country last year
including the state of florida where we
are now in pennsylvania and north
carolina and ohio every place
with the greatest economy we ever had we
had to close it down we saved two
million lives we're opening it up we
have a v-shape
and it's coming back it's coming back
very fast one other thing we really
helped the hospitals
we've sent videos remember guys the
question was what are you going to do
and he's like oh it's all fixed it's all
great masks
and gowns and we went into the
ventilator business because
this country was not equipped with
ventilators and i'm not blaming anybody
for it
but we're now making thousands of
ventilators a month
and we have all we can use we're sending
them all over the world because the
world needs them so
they've worked very hard and really very
very effectively thank you great
question
let's talk always put the mic close to
your mouth
okay go ahead mr president my parents
are as you heard both frontline
healthcare workers
and i've seen the physical and the
mental tools that this pandemic has
taken
on them firsthand as well as the
exacerbation of coronavirus due to
americans who are not wearing masks or
participating in social distancing after
contracting covet 19 yourself has your
opinion changed on the importance of
mask wearing
no no because i was okay with the masks
i was good with it but i've heard many
different stories on masks i mean
i had you know being president you have
people they bring meals they bring this
and i had an instance recently where a
very wonderful person is bringing me a
meal and he's playing with his mask and
he's touching his mask all over the
place
and then he's bringing a plate in and
i'm saying well i don't know if that's
so good
i mean the good news i didn't eat it
okay i did i decided not to eat it this
was a month ago but i looked
you have on the masks you know you have
two stories you have a story where they
want a story where they don't want
i am all for i don't get that because
it's just all of your public health
officials your administration
they're in unison about this they're all
in unison about it
the university of washington which is a
stud is a that you have a model that
your coronavirus task force relies on
says that if everyone wore a mask you
could cut expected deaths in half
60 000 well what is that scott atkins if
you look at scott
dr scott he's from great guy stanford he
will tell you god atlas is a
neuroradiologist
who knows nothing about infectious
disease that's who trump's quoting here
because you have so much power and
influence as president you could go
to your you can require it at your
rallies
everyone put on a mask right now and the
university of washington says you could
save
us in washington and you have other
places to say different things you have
a lot
hey dr fauci said don't wear a mask
right at first but then everybody agreed
i don't know that he changed his mind
but then you have a report coming out
two days ago that 85
of the people wearing masks understand
how insane that is
85 of the people wearing masks catch
coronavirus there's probably 150 million
people
wearing masks it makes no sense
wow what a bizarre event so far
i mean really not making any sense two
questions from the audience remember
this is a town hall format and really
really wild stuff
uh we are going to be getting to the joe
biden town hall momentarily but let's
just listen to a minute of it
guarantee first term home buyers a 15
000
down payment for first term home buyers
in addition to that
what all the studies now show and i've
been arguing this for a long time
is young black entrepreneurs are just as
successful as white entrepreneurs or
anyone else given a shot
but you can't get the money where do you
go to get the startup money
so what president obama and i did we had
a program we took
a billion hundred million dollars and we
invested in all the sbas around the
country in the state sba small business
association
and that generated 30 billion dollars
came off the sideline because if you
have a guarantee of
200 000 for your new startup enterprise
young entrepreneur
you're gonna be able to attract if it's
government money as a guarantee you'll
be able to attract another
hundred thousand dollars it generated 30
billion dollars well i'm changing that
program and i'll get this done
without much trouble i believe in the
congress from
uh from 15 uh 1.5 million dollars
to 30 billion to 30 billion that'll take
300 billion
off the sideline and grow because you
know and for example
if you in fact and i were the same age
and we split our differences and we were
the same age and we went to the same
builder to buy us each the same home
but my home was in a white neighborhood
on one side of a highway and yours is in
a black neighborhood
same exact home your home will start off
being valued
29 less than my home yet your insurance
for that home will be higher
you'll be taxed more for it we've got to
end this that's what got me involved in
politics in the first place
oh my god guys it's it's paul he's
talking about like just hearing him say
anything compared to what we've been
seeing in the trump town hall is crazy
now remember the agreement we made was
because the biden town hall is longer
we're going to start with the trump town
hall
then go to the biden town hall and it's
going to be a beautiful thing i'm glad
everybody's here with me uh now
now more than 30 000 31 000 of you um
and i i really am thrilled that you're
here if you want to get your message up
on the screen and some interesting
messages have come come in
a lot of people like berg saying trump
is getting eaten alive right now
uh you can use the super chat function
um at the bottom of the chat window or
over
the chat window and always remember that
uh anybody who signs up at
joinpakman.com which is our number one
funding source
as you sign up in real time this blue
bar above me will fill up and
uh uh if we are lucky at some point we
will get to 100 and it will explode off
of the size of
off the side of the screen and
potentially take the stream offline
that's a joke no nothing bad will happen
but it'll be a beautiful beautiful thing
uh we are getting back now to the trump
portion of the town hall and then
at its conclusion we will get over
uh to the biden town hall when trump
returns i'm going to be uh
very very strongly refilling my my glass
with water
water right that's what we're talking
about uh and then i will be right back
with you guys in a moment
live in miami with president trump for a
town hall thank you again mr president
we have another voter now christy
alonso come on out christy she is
leaning slightly towards you she says
she voted for you in 2016. chrissy you
ready
take the mask off hold the mic close and
let's hear your question
thank you for your service mr president
thank you very much um we're a
hard-working middle-class family of four
my husband and i are both self-employed
and we have to get our own individual
health care
as you know health care costs have gone
up considerably
over the decades and you had originally
said you were going to repeal replace
obamacare what is your plan now in 2020
to make health care costs affordable for
americans like myself
so we got rid of the individual mandate
on obamacare which was the worst part of
obamacare and now you could actually say
it's not obamacare because that's how
big it was where you had to pay a
fortune for the privilege of not having
to pay for
bad health insurance so we got rid of
that that was a big big thing
and by doing that and we will always
have by way we're always
protecting people with pre-existing
conditions and i can't say that more
strongly
but we've been able to bring health care
costs way down
now i took over obamacare got rid of the
individual mandate
made it good manage it much better
remember they had the 5 billion dollar
website disaster and all of the problems
they had
the problem with obamacare it's not good
we'd like to terminate it and we want a
much
less expensive health care that's a much
better health care
and that's where we're aiming and if we
can do that and we have a very good
chance of doing it
but we've also brought down the price of
obamacare
problem with obamacare it basically is
never going to be great and i want to
give
great health care mr president thank you
very much
on the pre-existing conditions this is
such a big issue for voters
it is a big issue in point of fact your
administration
is about to go to the supreme court to
argue to throw out the rest of obamacare
which includes the protections for
pre-existing conditions
so your administration is in court right
now trying to get rid of that protection
in order to replace it with a much
better health care
at a much lower we will sue everybody to
get rid of the pre-existing condition
protection to then put it back in and i
mean
maybe i changed the party a lot over the
last three years but we will protect
people with pre-existing conditions and
savannah what i want to do
get rid of the terrible obamacare i've
already done it to a large extent
because as you know the
the individual mandate is gone that was
the worst
repeal but you haven't replaced now
you've been in office almost four years
you have both houses of congress senate
and house
in republican hands and there is not a
replacement yet that's right i'm sorry
but if you look we had both houses and
what did we do we got rid of the
individual mandate that went through
this
look look we should be on the same side
i want it very simple i'm going to put
it very simple
we would like to terminate it and we
would like to replace it with something
that's much less expensive and much
better
which he doesn't have protect people
with pre-existing conditions
in november those pre-existing
the remnants of whatever is left because
we took it apart
we are running the remnants of whatever
is left much better than the previous
administration
which ran it very badly but we'd like to
have
new healthcare anybody understand this
less expensive let me get to question
number five and you'll like this he's
stuck in traffic his name is joe white
he is registered as a democrat he says
he's leaning
toward voted for hillary clinton in
2016.
and his question was a second stimulus
payment has been broadly agreed upon by
the republicans and democrats and yet
now we're in october and it's still not
passed
why not use your office to make the
second stimulus payment a
separate by the way guys the audio is
from the feed it's not i i get that the
audio is wacky
three packages but we're on our fourth
and
i agree with him 100 he should vote for
me the problem you have is nancy pelosi
she couldn't care less about the worker
she couldn't care less about our people
and
we should have a stimulus and i want a
stimulus the republicans will approve a
stimulus
the problem is she doesn't want to do it
because she thinks thinks it's bad for
her election
the fact is she's wrong because people
know she's in our way
she's not approving it she doesn't
appreciate our people and she doesn't
approve
appreciate it all our workers nancy
pelosi
we are ready to sign and pass stimulus
but she's going to do
but this has been a roller coaster back
in early october you one day tweeted
no more negotiations until election
until after election day i'm walking
away then i think the next couple of
days you said maybe we can do something
targeted
then you said i want a big big bill but
then senate republicans said
no we're not for that so you are the big
deal maker
you yourself have changed positions did
you ever hear a word
called negotiation we're negotiating
okay
he's mostly negotiating with himself
from day to day
and you know who i'm negotiating against
nancy pelosi because she doesn't want to
give the money
we should have stimulus this was not our
people's fault this was china's fault
and she's penalizing our people i'm
ready to sign a big beautiful stimulus
you saw the other day i say go big or go
home right
i want it to be big i wanted to be bold
i want the money to go to directly
the republicans with you they're going
to go big number they'll go they're
going to be okay
so they have not said that because i
haven't asked them to because i can't
get through
nancy nancy pelosi
and i through my representatives or
directly i don't care
if we agree to something the republicans
will agree to it okay
our next question comes from oh this is
interesting she voted for clinton in
2016 but recently changed her
registration
from democrat to independent she says
she's truly undecided her name is becky
lightman
hello becky what's your question how can
anyone be hi i'm great how are you
nice to see you good to see you so
corporate tax rates
are a hot button issue and you have cut
corporate tax rates
and your opponent joe biden is planning
to raise them
a lot of americans think that
corporations don't pay their share of
taxes and want to see those
tax rates increase what do you say to
those americans
to maybe tell them why you want the
corporate tax rate lower
and why that helps them it's a great
question we've created more jobs
than this country has ever created we're
up to 160 million jobs we were never
even close to that number
we were just hitting 160 million jobs
coming so consider now he's conflating
corp jobs created versus labor
participation it's whacked
on everybody including middle income
taxes which he wants to do
you will blow this thing and you'll end
up with a depression the likes of which
you've never had that's what's going to
happen
we have something that's really good the
reason we're coming back so strong is
because we built a very strong
foundation
companies are moving in car companies
are moving into michigan
ohio and to south carolina and north
carolina just today
so what's happening is they're coming in
because we reduced the taxes
our taxes our corporate taxes were the
highest in the world
and now they're among the lower taxes
they're not the lowest
but they're among the lowest and what
that means is jobs but also
we're doing a very big and we've done a
very big
middle income tax package so if we get
in we're going to do the middle income
tax package but it's a great question
is crazy if he comes along and raises
rates all those companies that are
coming in
they will leave you guys know this is an
economic question this is
supply side versus demand side stimulus
this is laffer curve this is you know
this is so many things that he just
doesn't even know
years of your tax returns among other
things it says that you have debts of
approximately 421 million dollars that
you have personally
guaranteed and that will come due in the
next four years
the question is on behalf of voters who
do you owe 421 million dollars
what they did is illegal number one also
the numbers are all wrong with the
numbers
and just so you understand when you have
a lot of real estate i have real estate
you know a lot of it okay right down the
road doral
big stuff great stuff i'm very under
when i
decided to run i'm very under levered
fortunately but i'm very under leverage
i have a very very small percentage of
debt compared
in fact some of it i did as favors to
institutions that wanted to loan me
money
400 million dollars compared to the
assets that i have
these properties all over the world and
frankly
the bank of america building in san
francisco i don't love what's happening
to san francisco i hear you right it
sounds like you're saying
400 million isn't that my biggest office
building
but are you are you are you confirming
that yes you do owe
some 400 million is that it's a tiny
percentage of my net worth and you'll
see that soon because
we're doing things you know we've given
i think it's 108 or 112 pages of
financial detail
to elections and you know we have to
file as
the president as any politician you have
to file nobody ever looks at that
when they do they see how incredible the
company is but more importantly
they see where this debt is no i don't
know russia money
i don't know i owe a very very small
it's low mortgages
people have a house any foreign because
it's so easy to solve
and if you'd like to do i will let you
know who who i owe whatever
small amount of money i want to say two
things number one it's a very small
amount of money
number two it's very straight it's very
very straight
but it's a tiny percentage of the worth
right did you ever hear the expression
under levered
here's the thing you could clear this up
tonight by just releasing your tax
returns yourself i mean
that's what i understand i think people
are just wondering
it turned out that i am on the road
excuse me
he can't be under audit for every year
just release the taxes that aren't under
audit you're not under audit forever the
irs and i'll go a step further
i'm treated very badly by the irs they
treat me very very badly
you have people in there from previous
administrations they treat me very badly
oh my god we're under audit it's very
routine in many ways but we're under
audit they like to change the game
change the rules do everything you saw
what they did with the tea party people
you saw what they did with the religions
that prohibits you from releasing your
tax returns common sense
and intelligence and having lawyers to
say because i would love to release him
and as soon as we come to a conclusion i
will release him and very badly
but he means the conclusion of his
presidency and if you take a look you'll
see 112 i think it's 112.
it talks about the income which is
rather massive
it talks about all of the properties
they have them listed
you can never learn more but you know
what happened people went there all the
reporters went there was like a feeding
frenzy this was originally when i filed
it
and i file it every year i update it
every year my son is here
they run the company i don't run the
company
750 in taxes in the year you were
elected that's a statutory number it's a
statutory it's not
true i think it's a filing number you
pay 750 it's a filing
most people here probably know i don't
know i can tell you this
if they have oh my god returns as you
know guys it was statutory
but their numbers were wrong but let me
tell you what else
uh i don't owe money to any of these
sinister
people this has been going on for years
now russia russia russia turned out to
be a hoax
and it turned out to be that hillary
clinton and the democrats
were dealing with russia not me it's a
whole hoax
so i would not mind at all saying who
it is but it's a very small when you
look at vast properties like i have and
they're big and they're beautiful and
they're well located
when you look at that the amount of
money 400 million dollars is a peanut
it's extremely under leveraged and it's
leveraged super super relatable 400
million in debt is a peanut for trump
we'll get more voter questions right
after this
um this woman right here is out of her
mind and i just wonder like what are the
odds that that's who gets placed over
trump's left shoulder
in direct view of everything it's really
really stunning stuff
um a lot of people sending super chats
the havel says did you know paying 750
in taxes was being treated badly by the
irs
very very sad very very sad red rover
says that that woman is a plant with an
earpiece and is being told when to shake
her head yes or no
that that's silly it's it's obvious when
to do it any time trump talks you nod
anytime savannah guthrie talks you shake
your head
um if you're just joining us we are
watching the trump town hall which has
only about 15 minutes to go then we will
be switching to the biden town hall
which is also currently in a commercial
break
uh i am being asked whether i will open
the phones after this
ends um maybe i was sort of looking
forward to
going to bed but i mean listen i'll make
a deal if we get to our goal of a
hundred members and patrons
at joinpakman.com and patreon.com
davidpakmanshow
i will commit to taking some phone calls
i will do that otherwise i'm going to
bed i think because we've got a very
very long day
tomorrow with a lot of different
important important different elements
going on
nev shepard says the black woman in the
background is melissa tate a huge trump
supporter and a candace owens wannabe i
don't know if that's true maybe that is
true i
don't know who that is a daisy woman
says do i know of any fancy feline cafes
no i don't like cats and
and to be perfectly frank the last thing
i would do is go to a place where
the you go to be around cats that's not
something i would do
wendy beamish says tell that to a
homeless person 400 million is a peanut
yeah super relatable pro middle class
trump recently talked about how
uh great his new plane is air force one
compared to his
old plane of 757 and said that his 400
400 million rather in debt is merely a
peanut very very relatable guy
thanks to barbara marsden who is new
member number 63 today on my website i
appreciate
that some people asking if it's candace
owens
in the background i don't think it is
yeah people wondering whether trump is
trying to say
under leveraged i assume that he means
under leverage
i've never heard the financial term
under levered it's it's under leveraged
as far as i know
maybe under leverage is valid i'm not uh
i'm not sure um neil matt says in the
last 24 hours 538 moved the mission
the the main second district and georgia
to biden but ohio back to trump indeed
all you can do is vote all you can do is
vote the polls don't matter at this
point
love says david people keep asking you
not to mute when you talk we can hear
you both
please well we'll see we've tried all
combinations of that
nicholas asks if i have my telestrator
working yet it's it's not working great
you know i'll plug it in and see if i
can draw let's see
uh we will see i i have invested in a in
a telestrator pad
and i will test it for you guys oh oh
boy
um let's see it's it's doing something
yeah i'll work on that
when the thing comes back and we'll see
if i can this would be a perfect event
to do it i could signal particularly
unhinged audience members and that uh
that type of thing
john says he thinks trump fell into a
trap here
i mean listen i think that this is an
embarrassing fiasco
but there's probably some trump voters
who uh who think it's good let's get
back to it
we are live in miami in the middle of a
town hall with president trump thank you
again for being here we've got another
voter
adam sugar he voted for clinton in 2016.
he's registered as a democrat and says
he's supporting biden
adam take it away thank you savannah
thank you mr president thank you
four years ago senate leadership said it
was inappropriate to
push through a nominee in an election
year yet they fast tracked your nominee
for the supreme court just today
wow the question i have for you is how
do you
what do you say to the voter that thinks
it's hypocritical to act in that manner
and that they can't trust republicans
word
so when i was elected and when a
president is elected they're elected for
a period of four years
and justice ginsburg said it best i
think talking about president obama
having to do with somebody else that the
president has put there for four years
not for three years so during this
fourth year it happened to come up
unfortunately because i had great
respect for justice ginsburg but
a vacancy happened to come up and we
picked somebody that's
outstanding she has been an absolute
star
and i'm extremely proud of it but again
plenty of time i mean there's plenty of
time we're going to do it before the
election but we also have
much time after the election but there's
no reason to wait because it's almost
unanimous it seems to me certainly
within the republican party and frankly
most of the democrats
within closed rooms i guarantee you that
this is an outstanding person and
i'm using my fourth term and you know if
you look at it that if you put the shoe
on the other foot
if they had this they would do it 100 so
there's been 29 times when this has
happened all 29 times a president has
done exactly what i've done
[Music]
to the voter's point i'll just say that
in 2016 you were on another show
actually another morning show
and you were asked whether president
obama should nominate a supreme court
justice merrick garland and you said
i think the senate should wait until the
next president and let the president
pick now that was eight months before
the election
this is three weeks before that respect
by the way so you you have changed your
position on this i have a lot of respect
for judge garland i want to tell you
that
but i'll tell you the whole game changed
when i saw the way they treated justice
kavanaugh
i have never seen any human being and
i'm not just talking about supreme court
i have never seen a human being treated
so badly with false accusations and
everything else
i have never seen anything like it and
you know what the truth is savannah
like it or not the ball game changed a
lot there has never been
anybody treated so badly as now
justice kavanaugh you've mentioned that
you
would like to see amy coney barrett
confirmed to the supreme court
in case any challenges come up in
connection with the election
do you expect her to rule for you i
think she'll have to make that decision
i don't think she has any conflict at
all
you know a supreme court judge does not
have i mean they can make their own
decision
uh the and they actually have additional
power to make that decision
uh it would be totally up to her
i would think that she would be able to
rule either for me or against me be
i don't see any conflict whatsoever we
have an election coming up i think it's
the most important election in the
history of our country
if for any chance and it probably won't
and i hope it doesn't ever get to the
supreme court
but if it did i would think that she
would rule one way or the other i would
think so
yeah i have no idea
one way or the other believe it or not i
never asked her about it
i never talked about it i didn't talk
about any of the
obvious things that you could talk about
and i think a lot of people in my
opposition
might but in speaking to a lot of very
brilliant people and people that
do this for a living they say it's
better not to talk so i talked to her
about
life i talked to her about the fact
would you like to do this are you
willing to do this because it's a
tremendous burden
the answer was yes she's unbelievably
well qualified but i never spoke to her
about these various questions
let's get our next voter she's leaning
to you mr president she voted for you in
2016. she is a registered republican
her name is mariah greene mariah what's
your question thank you very much
thank you good evening mr president i'm
honored to be with you
you here tonight uh sir so thank you
i'm a pro-life millennial and my
question for you today is
if roe v wade is ultimately overturned
in the future
what protections would be put in place
or kept for where the mother's life is
in jeopardy in relation to high-risk
pregnancies
again i'm not ruling this and roe v wade
is something that
a lot of people would say obviously
you're going to speak to somebody i
also two other great justices
justice gorsuch and justice kavanaugh i
never spoke to them about roe v
wade i never spoke to them about
election laws i never spoke to him about
anything
and i've done the right thing from a
moral standpoint
question was abortion protection he says
this is the type of thing you would
speak to people about
i think depending on what happens with
roe v wade i think that perhaps it could
get sent down to the states
and the states would decide i also think
perhaps nothing will happen
uh i have not talked to her about it i
think it would be inappropriate to talk
to about it
because people would say you can talk to
about it i just think it would be
inappropriate
but what is your preference because it
agreed
you guys noticed there was nothing even
approximating an answer there right
roe versus wade overturned i would i
would like to see
a brilliant jurist a brilliant
person who has done this in great depth
and has actually
uh skirted this issue for a long time or
make a decision and that's why i chose
her
i think that she's going to make a great
decision i did not tell her what
decision to make
and i think protections for the life of
the mother i don't want to do anything
to influence her
i want her to get approved and then i
want her to go by the law
and i know she's going to make a great
decision for our country
most pro-life republicans would like to
see roe v wade overturned an abortion
ban
many of them would most of them would
i am telling you i don't want to do
anything to influence anything right now
i don't want to go out tomorrow and say
oh he's trying to
give her a signal because i didn't speak
to her about it i've done the right
thing in
so doing how she's going to rule you're
going to find out perhaps or you might
not find out i mean it may never get
there
it may never get there we'll see what
happens all right we have another
question
this is cindy velez she is undecided
she says she's leaning to biden and she
did vote for clinton in 2016.
she's registered as a democrat hi cindy
what's your question good evening
good evening mr president thank you very
much as the mother
of a young male of color i have raised
him to respect
authority not only because it's the
right thing to do but also
out of fear that he may face profiling
or be considered a criminal
as an educator i've also had similar
conversations with my high school
students
mr president what will you and your
administration do
to better prepare our law enforcement
officers to work in collaboration with
the communities that they serve
and also to protect the lives of
innocent black and latinos
from police brutality and injustice
right i fully understand the question
and
i saw everything that you saw over the
summer and it was a terrible thing a
terrible thing to watch
we were very strongly we have a senator
named
tim scott from south carolina he came up
with a bill that should have been
approved it was great it was a bill that
was
strong in terms of law enforcement and
strong in terms of
enforcing the proper thing and doing the
proper thing by law enforcement
and the democrats just wouldn't go for
it they wouldn't go for it at all and i
don't know why because it was a really
great bill but i do have to say this
and some people don't like it when i say
it but a lot of people agree
i have done more for the
african-american community oh my god
president with the exception of abraham
lincoln criminal justice reform
prison reform historically black
technologies and universities i got them
funded they were on a year-to-year basis
they could have been put out of business
as soon as our country had a little bad
year they would have said i'm sorry
we're not going to fund you i got them
10-year
funding and financing and more than they
even asked for i became very friendly
with a lot of the heads
but we've done more and of course
opportunity zones
but criminal justice reform everybody
said it could
it could not be done president obama and
biden never even tried to do it they
never even tried
but i say that and i say it often i'll
say it loud and i'm very proud of it
and i have a great relationship because
of what i've done
with the african-american community i'm
very proud of it let's go to our next
question we have paulette dale she
leaves wiley to fight in she voted for
clinton in
2016 she's registered as a republican
paulette what's your question
thank you good evening mr president
thank you very much i have to say you
have a great smile
oh my god okay
[Music]
you're so handsome when you smile you're
so handsome
of immigrants to the united states who
fled
eastern europe due to religious
persecution right
the united states immigration policies
are very personal
for me right surveys
show that most americans
and the majority of republicans support
the dreamers program so my question for
you mr president
is if you are elected to a second
term do you expect to pursue
your previous efforts to cut
the daca program why or why not
and the daca daca is somewhat different
than dreamers you understand that and
you understand it better than anybody
probably in this room
where do you come from by the way
originally my grandparents were from
russia and poland
that's very good okay so we are going to
take care of daca
we're going to take care of dreamer we
it's working
right now we're negotiating different
aspects of
immigration and immigration law we've
built
now over 400 miles of border wall
southern border
mexico is working very closely with us
we have the strongest border we've ever
had
we want people to come into our country
they have to come in legally but we are
working very
hard on the daca program and you will be
i think very happy over the course of
the next year
because i feel the same way as you do
about it
thank you very
are under your much no new applicants
are allowed and in fact the daca
recipients now have to renew
every year as opposed to every two years
so in fact
the daca program has been curtailed by
your administration what happened is
because of the pandemic
much changed on the immigration that was
that was from before the pandemic it was
heavily infected as you know and we've
made it very very difficult to come in
because of the pandemic
and other reasons and crime but we have
a very strong border right now and we
have to keep it that way but
we want people to come into our country
but they have to come in through a merit
system and they have to come in
legally and people are very very happy
with it you haven't heard any complaints
about that
but what happened is because of the
pandemic
we have to be extra cautious you have
been promising this immigration bill
since well at least july when you told
my colleague
nothing's come yet it's very happy that
the fact is
we got rid of catch and release which is
a disaster
you know you catch somebody they could
be a murderer they could be a rapist and
we're supposed to release them
into our country these are the laws that
i inherited we ended that program
now i think you're going to see
something very very good
the whole immigration if you look at
what's going on people used to pour into
our country
and especially during the pandemic i
think
has he directly answered any of the
questions
30 seconds left i think about people
sitting out there tonight there are some
who love you some of them are sitting
right around here
and some who will never vote for you but
there are people in the middle there are
people who aren't sure
there are people who want to know why
they should give you a second chance and
how you might improve in a second term
30 seconds what would you say to them
because they've done a great job the
strongest economy in the world
all the stuff he promised and didn't do
he's going to do around the corner the
vaccines are coming out soon
and our economy is strong we are at a
level with jobs like we've never been
before
we've rebuilt our military we've rebuilt
our borders we had no borders we had
known nothing
we've rebuilt so much we've given you
the greatest tax cut in the history of
our country
greatest regulation cut equally as
important
and we created new levels of jobs that
nobody thought was possible
and next year is going to be better than
ever before
i got to leave it there
mr president all right not a single
answer from donald trump in his town
hall we will now go over to the joe
biden town hall oh they're in a break i
guess so we will we will uh oh no here
we go
greetings for vice president biden thank
you mrs dolas
um in a 2012 report of the university of
pittsburgh's
institute of politics fracking was
discussed and it is possible
implications
for the waterways from the commonwealth
to the gulf
fracking has made the population sick
and killed wildlife in southwest
pennsylvania
the commonwealth of pennsylvania and
small business development centers
have already begun to transition people
away from fossil fuels
what industries that are not harmful to
human health
and the environment are you planning for
southwest pennsylvania
and the nation well first of all i
make it clear i do not propose banning
fracking
i think you have to make sure that
fracking is in fact not
admitting methane or polluting the well
or dealing with what can be
small earthquakes and how they're
drilling so it has to be managed very
very well number one
number two what we have to do is the
future
rests in renewable energy the single
fastest growing
energy source in the world right now
because
i'm going to say something that's going
to sound self-serving but i manage the
recovery act
and i was able to invest billions of
dollars into
bringing down the cost of the cost per
btu
of of wind and solar so now it's cheaper
than coal
is cheaper than oil right now and it has
great great promise in the last 30
seconds we've gotten more substance from
biden than in trump's entire thing
and so there are a number of things that
i would do immediately
number one there are over well over a
hundred thousand wells that are
left uncapped in the region we could
hire 128 000 of these people who are
working in the industry
to cap these wells and get a good salary
doing it now
number one number two we should be
moving toward
finding the new technologies that are
going to be able to deal with carbon
capture so
ultimately is the transition we moved
from from
to a net zero emission of carbon that
we're still going to be able to use
if we find the right technology some
gases
some gas to be able to if we can carbon
capture
and i think we're going to be able to
move in a direction where by the year
2035
we'll be able to have net zero
emissions of carbon from the creation of
energy energy creation that so we can
move it by
dealing with those and every time we
talk about
global warming or the environment the
president thinks
of of you know it's a joke and
i think it's jobs because what we're
going to have happen
is you'll be able to see now as i
started to say before
i as president is going to invest that
600 billion dollars we spend in
government contracts
only on those things that in fact also
are not only made in america but
building an infrastructure that's clean
and new and what we have to do is focus
on the transmission
of energy across the country from areas
relating to solar and wind
the reason is that they have not that
has not been mastered yet i met a lot of
people in silicon valley
the battery technology is increasing
significantly so you're going to be able
to have
for example solar on your home and a
battery the side this
by this by this as i'm showing you here
in your basement so when it when the sun
doesn't shine for five days guys we're
actually talking about energy policy and
the future of storing
alternative energy in fuel cells we're
actually talking about stuff i know that
that might be shocking to some people
million people to work by weatherizing
four million buildings
and two million homes because we'll save
tons and tons of energy or billions of
barrels of energy
over time and at the same time provide
significant employment
and a good union wages prevailing wages
let me stick on fracking for a second
you said you don't you don't want to ban
fracking as you know it's an important
issue here in pennsylvania not everyone
buys your denial
a member of the boilermakers local 154
sean stephanie
was quoted in the new york times today
saying you can't have it both ways it
says you can't meet your goal to end
fossil fuels
without ending fracking what do you say
to people like shawn who doubt your
denial because they think
you want to keep that promise makers
overwhelmingly endorse me okay
so the boilermakers unions endorsed me
because i sat down with him one in a
great detail
with the leadership exactly what i would
do number one
number two what i would do is i would
stop making i would stop
giving tax breaks and subsidizing
oil we don't need to subsidize oil any
longer
number one we should stop that and save
billions of dollars over sorry to
interject guys but if if i were biden
why not just go with something like
listen i i am not so short-sighted that
my plan is to come in and make fracking
illegal next year however
as a planet we should eventually be
getting off of all
fossil fuels making sure that every job
that's eliminated is replaced by a new
job
in in green energy like couldn't you
just say that instead of just saying i
want to ban it or i don't want a banner
for elimination
of all all non-renewable energy by 2030.
you can't
get there you're going to need to be
able to transition george
to be able to transition to get to the
place where we invest in new
technologies that allow us to do things
that
get us to a place where we get to net
zero emission including in agriculture
i've laid out a detailed plan
we should be taking the plan where we
allow
significant more land to be put in
conservation
plan deep root of plants which absorb
carbon from the air
and in fact pay farmers to do it we can
do things like pelletize
all the chicken manure and all the horse
manure and cow manure
and they can be and take out the the
methane
and use it as fertilizer and make a lot
of money doing it
for example right now down in and people
when i say that they wonder what i'm
talking about
the biggest carbon sink in the world is
the amazon
more carbon absorbed from the air error
diminishing
global warming in the amazon then all
the carbon emitted on a yearly basis
from the united states of america from
all
vehicles on all means so we have to use
our imaginations
we have to move in the direction as well
providing for
electric vehicles electric vehicles will
save
billions of gallons of oil crate
estimated not made wall street
one million automobile jobs mine's
plugged in
right now but we're lagging we're not
investing we're not doing any of the
research
got to take another quick break we'll be
right back
the uh the contrast is just
stunning and you know you don't have to
agree with everything he says you don't
have to think that
uh you know you can even concede that
joe biden has slowed down a bit from
where he was eight years ago when he
debated paul ryan but i mean it's just
night and day
um let's see joshua says if i give you
five dollars will you stop
muting every 10 seconds i'm limiting my
muting i'm limiting my viewing
muting very very powerfully thanks to mo
smith who is new member number 80 today
at uh joinedpakman.com very much
appreciate that people asking will i
take phone calls tonight
um i have said i will take phone calls
if we get to our goal of a hundred
members otherwise it's been a long day
we had a lot big production day
powerful production day i'll probably
rap after the town halls but
uh but but i would consider taking some
phone calls
if people force me to take take phone
calls i will
um let's see here nm says
listen to how senile biden sounds with
his coherent answers
he didn't even insult anyone there's no
way he can run a country
yeah matthew saying this is so jarring
differently
i think you mean jarringly different it
almost hurts
very very uh very very much so and
brianna says i'm not 100
for biden but for the love of god why
not go back to sanity why would you
choose trump
and continue this madness well ask the
60 million people who were voting for
him
edward says biden is a brush of fresh
air
hope i can articulate as well at 77
and 35 edu says why is he so protective
of the fracking industry
are there snipers texting him headshot
picks
uh i hope that i mean listen it could be
as simple as he recognizes that
in pennsylvania it's an important
industry and if he just goes in and says
make it illegal
uh i mean listen here's the reality
biden even if biden said i will
immediately make fracking illegal he
couldn't do it
that's the reality so if i steal man the
reason why
it would be biden knows even if he says
i would ban it
that he can't actually do it and that
it's unlikely he would lose anyone
by saying i won't ban it because trump
also wants more more fracking
so it could be a strategic calculation i
don't love that stuff but i'm just kind
of thinking it through the way
uh that that the biden campaign uh maybe
thinking it through
ivan delgado says david pakman for
president i can never be president under
the current law
uh because i was not born in the united
states
i was not born in the united states so
that's you know good or bad i don't know
you tell me
thanks to marcos rojas who is new member
number 81 today
uh christine sales is number 82 and sean
scott is number 83 yes i i will stick to
my promise i will open the phone lines
uh via
the discord lines i guess we would call
them if we get to
100 members and patrons but if we don't
then
it's early bedtime for me so it's a
win-win-win either i get to hear from
some of you guys and we get 100 members
or i get to maybe finish i'm reading red
mars by kim stanley robinson right now
great book really really great book uh
i can go and uh and read that rick
sanchez says former d d
rat d d radicalized that could be a
double negative i'm guessing you mean
former de-radicalized trump supporter
david please help them a lot of them
like me were brainwashed from the
right-wing youtube
pipeline that's tragic
that is tragic um all right we are
getting back to
the joe biden town hall if you joined us
earlier we started
almost two hours ago with a pre-show and
your questions and comments
we then watched the donald trump town
hall on nbc
with savannah guthrie and now we are
watching the joe biden town hall
from philadelphia on abc news
moderated by george stephanopoulos i
have to tell you it's not just
the answers but even the questions i
think
have been better during the joe biden
town hall curious
to hear from you guys
christopher asks if i've heard about the
new ghost pepper donut at dunkin donuts
will i try it you know despite living in
massachusetts i have not been to a
dunkin donuts in close to 20 years
uh i have not been to any fast food
restaurant really for that long
other than the kfc incident which we
won't talk about today president joe
biden the next
question comes from mark hoffman center
valley pennsylvania conservative
who voted for trump in 2016. oh boy
welcome to pennsylvania mr vice
president good to be back home i'm from
pennsylvania yes i know
scranton right yep so
peace is breaking out all over the world
our troops are coming home
serbia is talking to kosovo and the
arabs
and israelis are talking peace which i
believe is a modern day miracle what's
going on
that's president trump's foreign policy
deserve some credit
a little but not a whole lot we find
ourselves in a position where we're
more isolated in the world than we've
ever been our allies
are uh our goat alone our you know
america
first has made america alone you have
iran
closer to having enough nuclear material
to build a
bomb north korea has more bombs and
missiles available to it
we find ourselves where our nato allies
are publicly saying they can't count on
us
we're in a situation as well where in
the far east we find ourselves
in in in the in the western pacific
where we're
isolated as well you have japan
and uh and and south korea at odds of
the other
china is making moves so i uh
you know i would say we find ourselves
less secure
than we've been i do compliment the
president on the deal
with with israel
recently but you know
if you take a look we're not very well
trusted around the world
when 17 major nations in the world were
asked who they trust
more who's a better leader and the
president came in behind both
the national survey international survey
both behind putin
as well as xi
and look what putin's doing you know you
have americans bounties on american
military's heads in afghanistan there
are more people there now by the way
than when i left when we left in
afghanistan
and we find ourselves in a situation
where he's talked to putin six times
hadn't said a word to him
and nato is on the risk of beginning to
crack
because they don't doubt they doubt our
concern whether we're there you see
what's happening in everything from
belarus to
poland to to hungary and the rise of
totalitarian
regimes in the world and as well as this
president embraces
all trump couldn't even name this many
countries he's best friends with the
leader of north korea sending love
letters
he doesn't take on putin in any way and
uh he uh
he is just uh he's learned the art of
the steel from
the art of the deal by she and china so
i i would
respectfully suggest no there is no
plan well no coherent plan for foreign
policy
you know we've always ruled uh we've
been most effective
as a world leader in my humble opinion
not just
by the exercise of our power the most
powerful nation in the world
but the power of our example that's
what's led
the rest of the world to follow us on
almost everything
he's pulled out of almost every
international organization
he gets laughed at when he goes to
the uh literally not figuratively when
he goes to the united nations
i mean it's just not it's not about the
president per se
it's about the nation and the lack of
respect that's shown to us
i want to get one more question in this
segment it comes from mika hack
she's from state college pennsylvania
this is your first presidential election
that you're voting yes hi thank you how
are you
i'm good thank you i'm the proud mom of
two girls
eight and ten my youngest daughter is
transgender
the trump administration has attacked
the rights of transgender people
banning them from military service
weakening non-discrimination protections
and even removing the word transgender
from some government websites
how will you as president reverse
this dangerous and discriminatory agenda
and ensure that the lives and rights of
lgbtq people are protected
under u.s law i will flat out just
change the law
every eliminate those executive orders
number one
you may recall i'm the guy who said i
was raised by a man
who i remember i was being dropped off
my my dad was a
high school educated well-read man who
uh
was a really decent guy and i was being
dropped off to
get an application in the center of our
city wilmington delaware
the corporate capital of the world at
the time and these two men i'm
getting out to get a an application to
be a lifeguard in the african-american
community because it was a big swimming
pool complex
and uh and these two men well-dressed
leaned up and hugged one and kissed one
another
i'm getting out of the car at the light
and i turn to my dad my dad looked at me
said joey it's simple
they love each other the idea that an
eight-year-old child or a ten-year-old
child decides
you know i decided i want to be
transgender that's what i think i'd like
to be
make my life a lot easier there should
be zero discrimination and what's
happening is
too many transgender women of color are
being murdered
they're being murdered and i mean i
think it's up to now 17. don't hold that
number
no separation it's higher now
and that's just this year and so i
promise you
there is no reason to suggest
that there should be any right denied
your daughter or daughters whichever
one or two one one your daughter that
your other daughter has a right to be
and do
none zero and by the way my son beau
passed away was the attorney general of
the state of delaware he was the guy who
got the first transgender law passed in
the state of delaware
and because of a young man who became
a woman who worked for him in the
attorney general's office
we've got one more segment coming up
thank you
all right joe biden talking policy uh i
mean you know
it's all the stuff about you know the
constant attacks on joe biden every
question he's asked he
immediately knows every single one of
the players
he instantly knows whether something
needs to be dealt with via executive
order
or by negotiating in the senate in the
house or whatever the case may be it's
just like we can't even compare what's
going on here to what we saw
there was barely anything to say uh
in terms of policy during the trump town
hall because there was no policy
discussed i mean it
the the contrast is really really
incredible
um okay are we there yet on call so now
we're very close
we we're at 94 website members and
we will we have about 11 minutes left i
will blow the phone lines open if indeed
we get to 100. um let's see here
helga crespo says just because biden's
not screaming and insulting like trump
doesn't mean he's senile greetings from
austria very late at night in austria
thanks for being with us
um daddy dame says my question to trump
if i was in that audience is why can't
you answer a single question we are
asking you straight
from abortion to health care yet donald
trump didn't answer
a single question remember he was asked
like just as an example donald trump was
asked
in situations if roe v wade is
overturned
what would you do for situations where
the life of the mother is at risk and
trump said
you know that may be something amy coney
barrett gets involved and it may not
we may see a repeal of roe v wade we may
not
but what the question was what
protections would you want to see
as an individual who claims to be
pro-life
although you know it's hard to believe
trump at 68 became pro-life
uh just just not a single answer um
asked by that sycophantic woman at the
end who told him how handsome he was
um what what should we do about daca
uh and trump says well you know daca and
dreamer
are two things and we're gonna do it
it's moving along very strongly and it's
all very powerful and lovely and
delightful and all the
the woman oh yeah yeah yeah yeah uh just
you
you can't even compare uh the caliber of
these two
events it is stunning let's see what
else we've got
um brianna says trump probably couldn't
even name the three branches of
government yeah i mean
you know it's like when biden names 20
countries and talking about the status
of the u.s geopolitically
you know trump would say i get great
calls and great marks from our foreign
leaders they all
privately tell me how great i am that's
what he would say
uh [ __ ] michelle doggo
says my dad thought trump did a good job
even though he was being treated
unfairly
oh boy i feel so sorry for you shel
that's really tough
did we watch the same trump town hall
yeah i i cannot imagine being in a
family situation like that i re that is
really really tragic
um i i just feel really bad for you
stu baker says biden has a smart doctor
for a wife vote biden hawaii
votes johann nielsen says biden sounds
like a normal politician
refreshing a junior charles wants a
biden
2020 chant i guess i mean if you want to
chant at home go ahead
it wouldn't bother me but i wouldn't
necessarily hear it
big thank you to louise nyberg louise
nyberg
is new member number 95
and adam matic is new member number 96
wow i might end up opening the phone
lines isn't it is it not looking that
way or what
we're now just four away i was looking
forward to going to bed but it looks
like people will force
open the phone lines um 97
is aaron doherty it is
getting very very close this this might
be over very soon
98 oh boy is robert regalfie
new member number 98 today
i think the phone lines are opening
aren't they i think it's happening
david could you write a piece on the
differences on town halls
you know i'm so busy i don't have time
to write stuff at this point i mean i'm
writing for the show but i will think
about it i'll do a segment on it for
sure
uh back to the last segment here
devinopolis
and welcome back to our town hall with
former vice president joe biden the next
question comes from keenan wilson
narbirth pennsylvania democrat
thank you good uh good evening um
you say that you committed to entering
this race after the events
of charlottesville in 2017.
i assume that that feeling that prompted
you to run will not go away once the
results are determined
so hypothetically if you lose
how will you use your platform to urge
president donald trump and those
rallying behind him
ugly towards the ideals of a more
perfect union
well to be very honest with you um
i think that's very hard he is not
[Music]
things have not led themselves to him uh
learning from what's happened what's
gone before
correct instead of being chastened by
being one of the few presidents the only
president to be impeached and then have
a member of his own party vote to expel
him
and embolden him so but what i will do
i will hopefully i'll go back to being a
professor at the university of
pennsylvania
and making the case that i've been made
and at the biden institute at the
university of delaware
focusing on on these same issues
relating to what constitutes
decency and honor in this country hope
that doesn't happen
it's just a thing that got me involved
in public life to begin with
as a kid i moved from scranton where
there were no african-americans and
moved down to
clemont delaware and and in delaware we
have the eighth largest black population
as a percent of population it was an
epiphany for me seeing what was going on
and i got deeply involved i know great
shakes i don't mean i'm
i wasn't john lewis i don't mean to
imply that
but it's the thing that's motivated my
dad used to have an expression
for real he said everyone's entitled to
be treated with dignity
everybody and it was real everybody is
and so whether i'm a defeated candidate
for president back teaching
or i'm elected president it is a major
element of everything that i'm about
because it reflects who we are as a
nation
and it's what makes us this is every
single solitary generation
the dial has moved closer and closer and
more and more to inclusion
and we are a country that is a country
of
slaves who came here 400 years ago
indigenous people and everyone else is
an immigrant
and we're a diverse country unless we
are able to treat people equally we're
not we're just
never going to meet our potential but i
think the american people want to see
that happen
i think they're ready to see it happen
and i tell you one thing if i'm elected
president
you will not hear me race pain you'll
not hear me dividing you hear me trying
to unify
and unify with bring people together
when i said i was running because i
wanted to unify the country people said
well there are the old days
we better be able to do it again great
you better be able to do it again mr
vice president if you lose
what will that say to you about where
america is today
well it could say that i'm a lousy
candidate and i didn't do a good job
um but i think i hope
that it doesn't say
that we are as racially ethnically
and religiously at odds with one another
as it appears the president wants us to
be
usually you know the president's in my
view with all due respect has been
divide and conquer
the way he does better if he splits us
there's division
and i think people need hope i think
look george i've never been more
optimistic about the prospects for this
country than i am today and i really
mean that i think the people
are ready they understand what's at
stake and it's not about democrat or
republican
if i get elected you know i'm going to
be i'm running as a proud democrat but
i'm going to be an american president
i'm going to
take care of those who voted against me
as well as those who voted for me for
real
that's a presence too we've got to heal
this nation because we have the greatest
opportunity of any
country in the world to own the 21st
century and
we can't do it divide it one more break
we'll be right back
this is mongolia and we are not an event
what an event very very different than
uh what we saw
with donald trump there is one more
segment here and then listen you guys
did it we got to a hundred new website
members so we will be opening the phone
lines
um it is davidpakman.com
discord that's how you can get on if you
want
um i will be giving very specific
instructions momentarily after
uh the conclusion of the town hall i
want to hear from you i want to hear
your thoughts and you will have the
i'll take a few phone calls i i don't
even know why i call them phone calls i
think it's just habit
but davidpakman.com discord
is the official david pakman show
discord if you want to get on with me
go into what is called the waiting lobby
click
the waiting lobby and then change your
nickname
to name from wherever you are right so
like you could
you know if your name is i see john from
new york you right-click your name in
discord
and you change it to john from new york
so i know
uh who we're talking to and uh and
and all of that that is the way to do it
um we will do that after
the biden uh town hall concludes and i
see people very very
excited there um yes the discord is
is very much it's it's highly explosive
because of what's going on right now
darren gross says i lost a few iq points
when we watched trump thanks to joe
biden i got him back
mark fillion says you know what let's
skip the election and give biden the
keys to the white house yes it doesn't
work that way
it doesn't work that way benjamin has an
interesting question david what does
trump even
want like what is even motivating him
he's not an ideologue i mean is it just
straight up thirst for power oligarchy
yeah i think he's in too deep and it
would be too damaging to his ego if he
were to lose at this point i think it's
that simple
uh and he's so delusional that he thinks
he really
is the the best and only person to be
president i think he believes that in a
serious way
um it's a very very deep deep delusion
for sure
if you joined us earlier we two hours
ago did a
town hall pre-show we then had a donald
trump town hall
from eight to about nine pm eastern time
we've since been on the joe biden town
hall which has been
dramatically more substantive um
joe biden for example mentioning
countries that exist other than
china in blaming them so that's very
different as an example
joe biden mentioning policy mentioning
energy generation mechanisms as an
example
and you know some softball questions
toward towards the end which we also saw
um uh a little bit in you know the trump
town hall where a woman told him how
handsome he is when he smiles which was
an interesting
interesting moment evan says we can own
the 21st century
biden 2020 very strong statement
extremely strong statement there we
expect
that the biden town hall is only going
to go somewhere between
5 and 10 more minutes a much longer town
hall than donald trump had
not sure if or what it says about
stamina strength or
endurance but it is interesting that the
biden town hall
has been significantly longer already
and i know that there's been a lot of
speculation about that
it is sort of troubling i have to say
for for what it says for the country
that viewership is down for our stream
uh by about 20 from where it was during
the trump portion
and i get it trump's more entertaining i
understand what's going on
i'm hoping it is not indicative of
anything related to
what the upcoming election results are
going to look like i re i really hope it
has nothing to do with that and it is
merely
hey people know they're voting biden
they don't need to watch him and trump
is more entertaining because he's wacky
but we will see very soon in just two
and a half weeks and we're wrapping up
our town hall with former vice president
joe biden mr vice president as you know
president trump had a town hall meeting
tonight
as well during that town hall meeting he
was asked several times whether he took
a covet test
the day of your last debate you're
supposed to have another debate a week
from tonight
just two quick questions do you expect
that debate to happen
will you demand that president trump
take a test that day and let it be
negative before you
debate yeah by the way before i came up
here
i took another test i've been taking
every day the deep test you know the one
that going both
and because i wanted to be able if i had
not
passed that test i didn't want to come
here and not you know expose anybody
and uh i just think it's uh
it's just decency to be able to
determine whether or not you are
you're clear and it's not i'm less
concerned about me but then the people
the guys of the cameras the people
working in the you know
the the secret service guys you drive up
with all those people
and so yes i i i believe he will do that
look i'm going to abide by what the
commission rules
call for i was prepared to debate him
remotely which was supposed to happen
and he said he wouldn't do that
you know a virtual debate our town hall
he didn't want to do that that i didn't
set those rules the commission said the
rules
so whatever rules they set uh and i'm
confident that the cleveland clinic is
the one overseeing it
i think they're going to not let happen
what happened last time they're going to
demand
let's hope it's safe but you expect to
be there well i expect to be there mr
vice president thank you for your time
tonight thank all the questioners here
it was really terrific questions i think
you did a service to our democracy
tonight thank you very much
i want to go back to my colleague david
muir in new york all right george thank
you
all right ladies and gentlemen that is
the end of the joe biden town hall
of course earlier there was this um uh
donald trump
town hall which we watched and maybe
we'll just kind of play in the
background i will
as promised listen i uh i keep my
promises i said if we got to 100 new
members i would open up the discord
lines
we got to 125 which is an even higher
number
as far as arithmetic is concerned it is
an even higher number
and um just absolutely incredible stuff
let's go and pick up on some people here
let's see if we can do this
it worked beautifully last time i'm
gonna try it
let's go first to uh
ariel from arizona ariel from arizona
can you hear me can we hear you is the
next relevant question
yeah can you oh my god are you there
ariel
ariel oh my god all right well ariel is
uh
ariel is re-muted let's try oh i don't
know
let's go to let's go to cat from
sacramento
cat from sacramento you are on
hello can you hear me yes i can hi
so um i just voted yesterday so that was
my first time 18 excited for that
did you vote by mail or in person by
mail
love it yep um
so one of the things i'm kind of
i was kind of worried about and stuff
it's like
there are a bunch of stupid people in
the world and that's i'm not ashamed of
saying that there are legitimately a lot
of stupid people in the world
yes heck i don't want to using the um
word
the r word for it is not okay no we
don't do that
no no yeah we don't definitely don't do
that yep but
like so if i'm just wondering
if either one of them wins i don't know
but if either one of them wins
what does that say for like mental
health
for because i'm deeply concerned about
people's mental health
yeah no listen at this point between
four years of trump gaslighting and
eight months of pandemic
uh you're right to be concerned about
the
the public's mental health the goal
would be
a biden wins hopefully democrats take
the senate
things start to normalize in terms of
the virus
we start to disabuse ourselves of the
idea that the country
is invariably heading towards 10
20 years of trumpist insanity and and
hopefully things start to improve but
it's going to take a long time to dig
out from from
from several different perspectives and
i think you're completely right in uh
in your assessment yeah because
there are a lot of things going on and
some people especially those
on um um
are concerned i've talked with a lot of
people within my
um community i have a group chat that
i'm in that's
dedicated to autism awareness and we
have a
zoom call every tuesday about it
so i'm just like concerned i share your
concern i share my concern
your concern i'm glad to um hear that
you voted and
and i hope to hear from you again okay
thank you
thank you very much very nice uh okay if
you want to get on it is davidpakman.com
discord get into the uh get into the
waiting lobby and then
change your nickname by right-clicking
your name
and it'll be a beautiful thing let's go
to crystal from massachusetts crystal
what's on your mind today
um i just have to say that i um
when i i couldn't watch the trump with
you i just had to watch
all of biden because um i needed to see
somebody refreshing and
yeah um not yelling or just
i don't know it was just a lot i
understand i don't blame you one bit
so i did turn in for the second half and
i i did have to stop to do some
um something with my son but um i
watched most of
the biden and it was definitely
refreshing it was um
it was refreshing and how unremarkable
it was
yeah and it was just we we need somebody
like that
yeah that's intelligent and actually can
be
a president i also voted
right away as soon as i got my ballot
did it mailed it back out right away and
i i tracked it
and it has been received fantastic yeah
i'm mailing mine uh
i actually think on saturday i might
drive over to the dropbox
so i can you know have film myself
dropping it off and and and really you
know make up make a day of it so to
speak
but yeah i've received mine already and
i plan to drop it off in person
that's awesome yeah and i i actually i'm
sorry the last time you called on me
and i was nervous i didn't think i would
get picked i kind of
i got no i got a little sage right i
guess and and just
exit out of my app oh my god okay so you
would it was not a technical issue you
just
you aborted essentially yes i did i got
nervous but
all right well crystal glad we were able
to talk today my pleasure thank you
there is a crystal from massachusetts
let's see let's go to um let's go to ian
from
chattanooga tennessee ian what's going
on
ian from chattanooga tennessee you're on
live
can you hear me now yes i can oh okay i
have to unmute it myself okay
right appreciate it um
i'm curious um as i i'm somewhat
centrist
um you know when it comes to politics
right i think what always
uh legitimizes a political commentator
for me
um as kind of an honest person is when
they they break party lines
and they they kind of they they show
parts themselves you know parts of their
opinions where they're like hey you know
what
i actually agree with the other side a
little bit more on
x y or z issues so um i'm just curious
you know
where do you break of your general party
lines because you're obviously
you know you you lean more left what's
an example of something where you lean
more on the republican side because i
think that's a great way to kind of
uh yeah i guess in my mind at least i'm
sure i'm not alone in this kind of
legitimize you as an honest
um sort of um opinion in this area
listen with total peace and love i don't
think that this is a good way to judge
people because imagine that the two
sides were
you know a democratic candidate and a
white supremacist candidate would it be
indicative of my trustworthiness if i
could find something
that i agree with with the white
supremacists i don't know that i like
the premise
but but yeah that being said
uh i mean listen um you know there's
there's people in my audience who are
socialists actual socialists and
communists not joe biden right not
who trump says is a socialist but like
actual socialists i simply disagree with
them
uh fundamentally i am fine
with private industry and markets um
directing resources when for production
when it comes to things like
you know mobile phones and uh i i don't
want the government in the business of
making the mobile phones i don't want
uh to socialize ownership of every
you know audio mixer company like that's
that's just a dis now to say whether
it's with my side or not i mean i think
the point i'm trying to make is
i have sort of staked out my political
positions over time i think that
i believe i think the the left is very
on the same page about right-wing
anti-semitism and what that looks like
i think the left often ignores left-wing
anti-semitism including some of the
things we saw within the women's march
so
you know i don't know that it's any i i
think it's less about
i'm not even a democrat i'm actually you
know independent
but um i i would be skeptical about
saying that
if the sign of trustworthiness is that
they agree with someone from this side
or that side or the other thing i think
it's it's more about
are we am i presenting how i've come to
the conclusions i've come to in good
faith
and that's what i try to do absolutely
yeah i see what you mean i
i guess i i suppose it's not the one you
know sort of
uh litmus test as much as it is sort of
refreshing and such a
partisan uh culture to kind of hear
someone who
you know is definitely voting for one
person over the other to kind of
see the good side in the other so but
yeah i appreciate your answer all right
thank you so much great to hear from you
very very
excited from all of these phone calls
that are coming in
let's go yeah i'm just picking randomly
i'm just you know just kind of getting a
mix of people from different different
parts of the country in different parts
of the world
it could be anybody could be anybody
let's go
next to samantha in texas samantha in
texas what's going on
and you have to unmute yourself samantha
just so you know i've unmuted you well
i'm shocked i was not expecting to be on
the air but
and yet i just voted absentee um
and my question for you is why are there
so many positions that
are run unopposed uh by democrats
oh i i there's unopposed both democrats
uh you're saying where you vote there's
lots of where it's only a republican
yeah i'm in texas yeah there's some that
there's some like um offices that only
republicans are running for
yeah that's very common in massachusetts
you see it you know in very blue
districts
you will often have no republican
challenger in local races it's a very
common thing
the reason is that there are places
where i mean listen you never want to
say there's no chance but there is all
but no chance for someone from the
you know in a very red district who's
going to vote for a democrat
particularly when there's an incumbent
republican and it's sad
i wish it were different but alas there
are very red and very blue districts and
that's very common
and then i also have another question
yeah i talk to a lot of
conservatives within my family and one
thing that they always come back to
is what has joe biden done in the past
47 years for black people
and the only thing that i can really
just combat with them
is that you know the national black
caucus supported the crime bill
overwhelmingly so he's changed his mind
and he's come around on a lot of things
but i just i can't get back to
the core argument that he hasn't done
anything for the black people
i i would immediately say why are you
asking that question we have
we have an election right now where we
have
donald trump and we know what that is
and we have joe biden and we know
what that is he was vice president for
eight years this
even if someone mentions 47 years it's
already a problem that's a trumpist
talking point of no meaning whatsoever
the the question is what are the
policies
right now that trump is running on you
can't even tell he has no policies he
doesn't list them but you have to look
at the last four years
and what is it that biden is running on
and when you look at biden's tax plan
it is a a of significant
uh benefit not only to the middle class
in general but disproportionately
to minority voters when you look at
biden's health care plan i mean it's
like 40
as soon as 47 years comes up that's a
red flag to me
i agree 100 and i love your show and
just it was good to talk to you
all right samantha my pleasure the
pleasure is all on this side of the
microphone i am so glad that you called
in
let's continue our tour around the world
by going next to uh let's go to
um oh i don't know let's go to
tyler from toledo tyler from toledo
what's going on
can you hear me david i can hear you
tyler excellent
um so my girlfriend alyssa and i
love watching your show i just wanted to
say that and thank you i'll make this
quick
but um i just really don't understand
i'd love to be able to wrap my head
around
why people continue to to support trump
i mean
lays it all out there he has plans and
he hasn't really said anything that i
just blatantly disagree with
i just yeah i just can't wrap my head
around it really
it it's so when whenever 60 million
people do something like support trump
different people do it for different
reasons there are people that are
supporting trump
because they will never vote for a
democrat so you've got that group
there are people who are supporting
trump because they are actually in the
group for example that will benefit from
trump's tax policy
there are people voting for trump
because they got tricked into it in 2016
and they don't even want to admit to
themselves that it was an idiotic thing
so they're going to do it again
you know there's no one answer to that
question sadly
right yeah that makes sense yeah and uh
yeah i'm excited i i'm hopeful that
biden can win
and i particularly um alyssa and i both
we
we like his energy plan and i i've been
saying
for as long as i've been involved or
cared about politics i've been saying
job opportunity there and i love that
that's like a main focus for him
i agree with you the one thing i would
like to see biden do better with and he
did it a little bit tonight is address
this fracking issue in a way that's less
defensive about i did or didn't say i
would ban it which obviously he can't
even do
and more about how this isn't even going
to be a question
because in parallel with getting off of
fracking we are going to be creating
more jobs than that will eliminate
and er it's you know i think he could do
better on that but he certainly went in
that direction tonight
right and i think it's also important
when he's touching base on that
and hopefully he will that it's made
clear that there is a transition plan in
place for people that would
be affected by that and he kind of
actually did mention it tonight in a way
i've not heard him do before
right yeah that was yeah it's good to
hear yeah
all right thanks very much i appreciate
the call and uh say hi to alyssa for me
all right thanks david you're very good
there it is uh wow tyler with a very
powerful message coming in
strong from toledo let's go
next and i listen i can't get to
everybody we're just kind of going going
through a different
uh different thing hey this is
interesting paulina from
argentina is on the line
oh my god i can't believe it hola
hola
hola hi can you listen to me yes i can
hear you and we can do this in
english or spanish however you please
well i'll try to do it in english i am
lee but my name is argentina
and this is so exciting i wasn't
expecting this
um but my main
worry with everything that's going on in
the us
as someone who doesn't live in the us
is the effect that might have that
trump's
either gets elected against in power
or for you know the whole region
everything that's going
on in here i don't know you know about
the new dictatorships that we have here
in south america
yes so yeah that's my main worried
actually
uh your worries are completely released
in the future you're right to be worried
and
you know our european friends are
worried our asian friends are worried
our african friends i mean everybody's
right to be worried because it's
it's been a disaster so i i mean i wish
i had something
more optimistic to say
yeah especially
considering like you know the background
the history that the u.s has
um affecting the politics and economics
in south
yes in south america and central america
so
um it's kind of frustrating seeing
everything that's going on there
and have like no voice but um
we are very affected by everything that
happens
in politics in the us absolutely and
paulina
just to do some because the everything
is so negative
just to do something positive let me
change topic altogether
can you tell me because of the virus i
haven't been
to buenos aires for a little while now
is there
a new type of alfajor that i maybe have
not tried
that is very popular right now that i
should try next time i go i've read
that havana now has a dark like a very
dark chocolate called like the black one
now is that good
well i haven't tried havana because it's
kind of the experience
always wow more of a horijitofan
yes i mean that's a classic
that's a good one now let me ask you do
you go with the mini or the full size
but actually
uh okay
oh full size full okay very good i i was
about to kick you off
if you said minnie that it was over
yeah okay paulina i really appreciate
the call though i i really do appreciate
in twitter we're starting to have a bit
of a delay i think we're having some uh
a problem with the connection but i
really appreciate it mucha gracias
okay there it is uh first call we've
ever taken from argentina i love that
all right let's see who else we've got
here
um let's go to uh let's go to josh from
arkansas
as some call it i call it arkansas josh
what's going on
um david can you hear me i can hear you
loud and clear
um first off um i love watching you
watching your show
um for a guy like me who wasn't really
much into news you're really good about
about filtering out all the bs and
making it easy to understand
thank you so um
i guess i mean i have many questions but
i guess my my question being that we're
getting down to crunch time
if biden was to win by a landslide how
do you feel that trump will react and
how do you feel his base will react
if if the blowout is by the biggest
margin
imaginable you know i've kind of gained
this out and i could convince myself of
different things depending on my mood
like
if it's a biden blowout the base will go
absolutely crazy
and they'll be become violent and trump
is going to do daily town halls and go
completely bonkers
in the end i actually think that if it's
a landslide victory for biden
you're not going to hear from trump
supporters you're not going to hear from
trump
trump will eventually just go quietly
and then republicans will pretend like
it never happened i think that if it's a
blowout that's what will happen
okay and um another question if i may
yeah um on the um if
heaven forbid trump does get re-elected
i know you you had mentioned about
you know don jr and eric for the next
four years but yeah i've been kind of
i've been kind of pondering like if
trump gets elected again obviously
he can't change the constitution to run
again he'd be 78 in four years
yeah but um but but but with all of this
you know mass
because i mean just just looking at
these rallies of like
how these trump supporters being what
they are you know how do you think
you know once his term heaven forbid if
he gets another
term how do you think that on that all
go how do you feel that all ends from
there
well you're saying in terms of what's
the future of the republican party or or
what happens with the primary
not necessarily the republican party but
like but like
trump's like hardcore base that he
appeals to
i worry that trump-ism which listen if
trump loses we'll still have 60 million
trumpists in the country that's a real
problem you've got to deal with i don't
know how you deal with that
but i think if trump wins trumpism will
not be an aberration and it will be
around for
for longer than any any of us would like
to believe it will be
and i don't know what would have to
happen but i'm trying to take it a step
at a time but that will be a major
problem that has to be dealt with
okay so i mean i mean and just kind of
because
you had mentioned don jr and eric i mean
dude do you think with with them being
who they are
do you think they they have a snowball's
chance in hell of getting elected not
about who they are
it's about who is the republican
electorate and sadly if trump had a
chance to become the republican nominee
eric trump or don jr or ivanka have a
chance at becoming the republican
nominee
if trump gets four more years and sets
them up beautifully i think it would be
a
major major issue okay
so yep um that that's all i've got for
for tonight and thank you very much for
for letting me talk to you my pleasure
all right great to hear from people this
is this is wild we've got a
a variety of different calls coming in
let's go
next to uh oh you know what let's go to
alaska jennifer from
anchorage is on the line uh jennifer
what's going on
hello david how are you uh long time
listener
so you know the the one big comment i
really wanted to make was
how wonderful having the town halls were
because you actually got to hear
more of biden's positions on policies
yes um without being interrupted by
trump of course right
and one big thing for me being in alaska
is our state is is dominated by oil and
gas
right so climate change and
the the push for moving to a renewable
energy
is is kind of a big deal for some of us
um and it's funny because i've actually
worked in oil and gas for the last
decade and i
used to be you know drill baby drill and
now i'm like the complete opposite
interesting but so is there are there
people are there people in alaska
who were it not for the issue of of
democrats
more wanting to get off of fossil fuels
who were it not for that would
definitely be
voting for more democrats but because of
that one issue continue to vote for
republicans
it's really funny that you mention that
because during the uh
the caucus for uh for bernie and hillary
back in 2016.
bernie sanders won by 82 percent
um during that primary he got more votes
i believe
than cruz and trump combined
um but because we were
uh super delegated to clinton
right um cruz still won the vote here
but we do have a lot of republican
incumbents that want to
open anwar to drill to frack
uh do offshore drilling i'm sure you've
heard about the
um the deregulation of areas to be
yes explored and extracted of course a
lot of us
are against that but most of the
opposition
says if you don't like our way of life
don't come up here don't
we don't want californians coming to
alaska and changing and it's like
yeah wow i mean this is not
we're more progressive than than i think
most people think
but again we have we have a local
uh government local uh runners
who try to become um who try to push a
more progressive platform but
don't really make it to um the general
election
interesting interesting that's
interesting to hear yeah i mean just the
internal dynamics of alaska
politics and primaries are not something
i'm super familiar with
unrelated um so in anchorage
how what's when the days get the
shortest when is sundown
um well it is almost six o'clock here
now
and the sun is setting it will be it
will be
dark by eight o'clock but it changes
every day
until december 21st right no now i
understand that's in the whole country
but what i mean is on december 21st when
is sundown
in anchorage oh usually about
uh 4 p.m okay that's not i mean okay we
i mean we get 4 45 in boston it's not as
different i guess it's
more northern alaska where it gets a
little wackier right
uh yes actually so up in prude bay which
is the
the northernmost tip of alaska yeah um
you actually have 60 days of darkness
wow that is not for me yeah no no it's
not for a lot of people but you know uh
one once a week tan
for about 10 minutes and and you'll get
through it wild
wild so yeah all right gentlemen that's
all i have
thank you so much thank you so much very
nice to hear i don't know that we've had
too many calls from alaska before
let's see who else we've got here
there are just there's so much going on
here it's really really crazy
let's go to maria from new york maria
from new york you are on what's on your
mind
oh hi david how are you good how are you
uh
i'm good actually my question for you is
um
do you ever feel disenhearted by
the state of politics now because yeah i
feel like
i feel like every time i watch politics
i feel more and more like i want to
move back to my native country which is
what
uh dominican republic okay well yeah i
mean listen that
that i understand why you're saying that
it's it's real yes i feel disheartened
all the time and you know
i'm i'm getting through with the idea
that we may
right the ship a little bit in november
and
start getting back in a more logical
direction but yeah every day is
extremely disheartening right now
yeah i really hope i really hope baton
wins because if trump wins i don't i
don't know
would you actually consider moving back
to dr if trump were to get reelected
oh yeah absolutely wow i i don't think
i don't think i would bear four more
years of this
and now how long have you been in the
u.s i've been in the u.s
um maybe 10 years now okay so you've
been here some time yeah
yeah yeah maybe more actually i don't
remember i came here for freshman year
of high school
okay all right well listen i hope biden
wins and i hope you stay ah thank you
let's hope so all right maria thank you
so much great to talk to you today
uh all right guys that does it for me i
really appreciate hearing from everybody
glad you joined me it's been quite a
night out
really everything has been said i can
never get to everybody people get very
very mad
but we will take calls again excellent
callers tonight
i think the callers were better than the
people asking questions in the trump
town hall to be perfectly frank i'm not
going to i don't i'm not going to
exaggerate
i'm not being hyperbolic but i want to
be real with you guys
but thank you so much for joining me we
will stream again so
soon it'll seem like i didn't even take
a break
you